je t'ai de sibérie mais tu est et ouest
étaient pas
géopolitique pas officiel l'as lattes
était dans le studio chemise chemise
blanche tu es très très chaud et donc on
va suivre ensemble balas on est coincé
sixième ronde déjà 5ème
6ème
ça commence très très fort
on au 6 36 6 j'ai bien travaillé les
nôtres c'est bon donc à temps on va
rajouter la caméra on va changer
nombreux mark fabbi be on aurait pu on
aurait pu laisser ça fait toujours
plaisir mais
que le fameux libye a changé
donc ça c'est bon la caméra on va se
mettre en grande calmes au début de la
partie je pense que tu seras d'accord
parce que ça fait plaisir de les voir et
en plus tu connais bien ali raisin parce
que tu as été son capitaine en équipe de
france ouais
donc tu vas pouvoir nous dire un peu ce
que tu ressens déjà des castes surprise
pas surprise surprise y a pas que le sol
et il a joué d'une fois des 4 x 4
il valait peut-être évité
petrov chez ces profs on sait pas trop
alors qu'est-ce qui ne prévoit cavaliers
f3 ou qu'elle essaie trop agressif j'ai
3 qu'est la surprise surprise catalane
où là c'est la marque de chroniques
c'est peut-être mauvais signe c'est
cramé qui joue aujourd'hui un point
madame chaude et
est-ce que ça sent la grosse prépa comme
pour les quatre premiers rangs nous ça
sent le
la prépa moyenne comme commis hier
énorme prépa énorme prépa est dans le
pré pas s'annoncer
il ya mille fois angers 2 en tout cas
caruana caronna qui a déjà tombé la
veste ils ont fait une blague pas mal
sur czech comme ils ont appris qu'à
roanne et par étage cherouati
c'était très content j'ai beaucoup aimé
on voit déjà les peaux qui se baladent
les poster extraordinaire il ya quoi y'a
une minute de jeu et déjà de vous
parler catalan ça peut être très très
aigu comme position pas forcément comme
une petrov plate partir du mans les
blancs sacrifie le pion ces quatre gars
du goût du gros contre je reste à savoir
quelle ligne ça va être des fabiano doit
être très près aussi hein parce que ça a
été remis à la mode par par carl benz
invérifiable
ouais il faut qu'on mette partie s'ils
souhaitent payer des petites
choses à changer ça tu as mangé aussi
j'avais laissé partie 5
comme quoi
et puisque demain c'est jour de repos
donc là il peut vraiment se permettre de
jouer longtemps
et tout donner car ouanna qui se lavent
déjà lui aussi
parce que car on a été un adepte de
celle là où il joue et jouer notre ligne
et ben je ne ne peux pas te dire parce
que là on est quand même dans la
finition la plus jouée de la catalane
la ligne classique où les noirs ajouté
petit rock
c'est vraiment la grande grande arista
grandes grandes lignes
sûrement c'est pas la ligne que je
jouais ou
bon ça c'est ça va c'est y connaissait
jusque-là
paris simpl c'est rare l'idée c'est
simplement de reprendre en ckd roland
j'aime plutôt dame ces deux
c'est quoi la différence de avec dams et
2,4 md trotz a obligé de manger
tu te relèves une ancienne fonction quoi
après doit y avoir une subtilité
en fête et une subtilité par rapport au
fait que si les blanc et noir jouent la
ligne avec ses six
et nous on joue qu'à et c3 ouais on est
directement mieux placés en d3 on
protège quand même le punto donc en fait
sûrement le mur le meilleur coup sûr
dame détroit doit être la présence et 4
mais peut-être que c'était pas la ligne
qui avait prévu caruana quoi donc la
dame français calcea 6 non ils veulent
amener quelque part bonjour d'amener 3
tu veux amener ton adversaire sur un
sentier que tu connais très bien après
c'est peut-être pas la seule option du
coup de prendre ces quatre noms après
bon il ya ces 6 1 mais hors du coup ses
six à temps il ya sur la petite basses
chaises comme il ya très peu de parties
peut-être j'avais été joués il n'y a que
six parties
mais carlo où il veut provoquer des
princes et 4 ça c'est sûr
c'est fou se donnent des trois
donc fuir ou une nouvelle fois ouvert
ans arras vérifié pendant la partie mais
on peut dire très bien préparée quand
même dans le sens où bat une nouvelle
fois c'est quand même lui qui a le la
première frappe dont l'ouverture qua
non là on a quelque chose de gros l'un
is love il a surtout on ne voit là on
sait que ces chroniques là qui a par
ailleurs la partie contre et pour on
sait qu'il y avait du
duce par enough qui étaient présents
parce que c'est là il est très fort sur
ses lignes hyper tactique
dam des 3
lanes ymir est derrière tout ça et car
on n'avait pas bien déjà on ne voit là
il commence réellement à apposer a posé
ses mains sur sur son visage c'est un
peu sa position
fétiche de
concentration
maximum
après les pattes il fait j'avais fait
une imitation une fois sur un life et
sapia prisme est comme ça puis comme ça
si tu le vois il change de miles a
changé l'a fait il est passé de ce tollé
la table
enfin sur une position toutes les
minutes ah tiens
mais quand il fait ça sert ans qui
calcule
contrerait contre mv l ogre ensuite j'ai
fait les mutations c'est qu'à un moment
donné lui sortait tout les premières
lignes de leur dis à chaque fois que
maxime juin qu elle c'était ça c'était
le festival
avec quatorze partis sur de chasse buzz
donc vraiment sur quelque chose de très
très nouveau
il ya hikaru qui passe voir
il lève les yeux donc ok
impressionnant d'ailleurs écart on
encore dans ce tournoi moi je le voyais
croyable là encore il peut ah oui s'il a
plus un c'est pas volé en fait
c'est un joueur d'exception quand même
cette sicav ou quoi qu'on en dise
vraiment extraordinaire on aime bien se
[ __ ] de sa gueule un prêt à se mentir
mais en fait il est vraiment allé
célébrer ce qu'il fait là il perd la
1ère et 2ème jour ils t'envoient une
partie
réagi tout de suite c'est un grand
champion
monstrueuse qui l'a sortie contre firent
oua el had et sa défense était assez
incroyable après c'est pas passé loin
quand même un peu de réussite sur salat
pour pour la peine c'est
plutôt dans les parties où il a eu de la
réussite ouais
autorisé de regarder les autres game ça
peut donner des infos
alors on a le droit d'aller regarder les
autres partis mais c'est vrai il y avait
eu 1 kg pas si toi tu as déjà vécu en
tournoi il a été similaire mais qui se
copient et vista au top 16 la entre
[Musique]
deux parties de mes coéquipiers rigueur
et freyssinet quand je jouais contre je
crois grande des lieux c'est jones
rigolo il se copier et skopje mais tout
le monde savait que freyssinet avait la
bonne ligne 1
mais bon après ça a très vite dévié mais
en tout cas c'est sûr que quand tu sais
que ta emeline que freyssinet second don
de 15 cents étaient sur le bon chemin
ouais moi c'était moi l'arbitré une
partie je sais plus dans quel tournoi
c'était maintenant mais il y avait du
shirov du kayak il y avait des mecs de
premier plan et l'arbitré avait
carrément déplacé
regardez il attendait en fait
c'était assez incroyable
disco pièces non non la partie dont je
parlais ils ont vraiment été déplacé ce
que là c'était il se copiait réellement
en fait
c'est quand même assez particulier
surtout qu'ils jouaient de la merde en
fussent
mai mais bon la sueur 1/3 des ouais bah
je sais pas c'est autorisé mais c'est
vrai que la question est épais pas et
pas stupide
quelqu'un saurait où peut-on trouver le
classement des candidats alors nous on
l'a à droite on peut le donner en gros
c'est simple c'est nepomniachi qui est
leader avec trois et demi caruana un
demi point derrière et puis un peloton à
50% avec rapporte nakamura et duda et
c'est ben ali reza est déjà distancé
quand même alireza way en dernière
position ex-aequo avec ding radjabov
c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
hors micro il a quatre fois les blancs
dans les cinq prochaines parties enfin
content là nul contre hand ou dahouët
honda donc sa seule chance c'est de
faire plus de 1 sur ce c'est à dire au
moins deux victoires et trois nuls sur
ces 5 partis il ya un déjà gaspillé une
a déjà gaspillé une est clairement
évidemment il va viser radjabov avec les
blancs est là aujourd'hui la chance de
revenir sur un des favoris
au titre donc partie très très
importante genre s'y perd aujourd'hui je
pense c'est terminé c'est hyper loris et
0% s'il perd aujourd'hui c'est perdre et
c'est fini ici fait nul c'est comme
compliquée s'il va finir la phase aller
avec un point de retard minimum sur le
carreau
noire les noirs demandons une partie
et s'ils gagnent on sait que les peaux
minatchy va sûrement avoir peut-être un
petit coup de mou comme et qui a une des
faits dès qu'il ya quelque chose c'est
toujours plus compliqué pour les peaux
comme cette première phase en 2020
on l'avait senti il était parti très
très fort avec trois victoires lors des
six premiers rangs et perdu contre max
allegri maxime et je pense heureusement
pour lui que le ton à cette arête oui
oui ça lui avait fait mal il était
revenu très solide et sur cette partie
il avait bien tenu dans la tête mais
qu'attend ça paraît un peu long pour un
dépôt
après il ya des absences c'est hier à
une absence par exemple il se sent bien
mais c'est une grosse absence il joue
très vite son ouverture pour être pour
se trouver très très mal mais tes
futures puissent et là il a eu de
l'attenté s'est passé hier mais bon
attention et puis caruana et digne tout
ça ça va être compliqué ap s'il en perd
une épaule il peut en perdre deux ans
perdent 3 fin
ça peut ça peut lâcher
arriver à faire tanguer caruana dans
l'ouverture en soi c'est déjà une
victoire c'est vrai c'est vrai que
réussir à mettre caroil en difficulté
aussitôt way assez surprenant la
banque clairement il veut pas faire
dépenser 4 parce que ça doit pas être sa
prépa sur dame ces deux êtres sa prépa
et c'est sûr que c'est sûr préparé par
ali reza donc ça c'est à mon avis ils
essayent de l'éliminer donc en soi et du
reste quoi il lui reste ces cinq
là la petite turbine est adéquat lycée
5es assises qui sont en réalité où
allaient deux coups les pins pas les
plus logiques mais ça fait partie des
coûts très logique les deux peut-être
réfléchir à si c'est vrai pourquoi
pourquoi si c'est moins précis
donc l'idée c'est simple c'est que si on
prend prend pourra jouer b5 alors là va
savoir
ce que si tu feras tu transpose non
j'imagine oui
alors est ce qu est ce que c'est une
transposition qui là est le problème
c'est qu'on sait pas vraiment
on sait pas dans quoi ils transposent ou
pas mais tu as la turbine est elle donne
déjà gros avantage mais non on marque
maliki bd de mal
il a joué ses 5 il nous enlève une épine
du pied en jouant quand même
ouais on commençait à se perdre un peu
on savait plus il faut quand est on
revienne mais est ce que quand on est on
connaît
je prends en aux corps et aux icaunais
un peu mais je veux la ddt surtout il
connaît très très bien là ouais j'suis
pas si koné dam des trois il viendra
nous dire tout à l'heure si connaissait
le coût
possible que non
en fait dam des trois est moins logique
le dam des deux ce que du coup tu je
t'aime tu te rajoute des rajouts des
problèmes ray
battait mal placée en fait non mais tu
facilite le choix adverse c'était mal
placé et puis des lignes en moins pour
les noires à connaître
ou la prison sekkat est pas forcé quand
tu la mets là d'avancer de se compliquer
la chose pour les pour les noirs ouais
même globalement en d3
d'amd 3g petit rocha tempo ok c'est pas
la case rêvée pour pour hind ahmas en
général n'ont jamais mais ont cependant
un fou à 6 à un moment donné allez juste
pas bien placé quoi
on laisse ce qui est sûr c'est qu'ils
veulent amener sur un schéma donc là on
va voir sur quel schéma qui veulent
amener il veut le forcer à prendre ces
quatre là dessus du sud en juin donne
des trois tu pousses l'adversaire à
prendre en c4 ouais
vraiment ce que tu espères
berne a toujours su non seulement il
connaît le coup mais liste avec suroît
les jouets way
en tout cas alireza un autre chose que
j'ai remarquée avec lui c'est que tant
qu'ils jouent tempo il connaît à rome
comme ça ça paraît un peu con mais il ya
des joueurs qui prennent leur temps même
quand ils connaissent n'y a pas de
calais rezaï a pas de moi c'est quelque
chose je sais pas toi qui l'as qu'il a
dirigé en équipe de france si tu
apprécies ça quand tu quand tu vois ton
joueur qui met la pression au temps où
si tu préfères qui temporise un peu qui
après il peut il amène une certaine
tranquillité aux coéquipiers à tours et
à nous et au capitaine en jouant vite en
rassurant montrant qu'il est lancé dans
ce schéma il adore aussi après après ce
qui est compliqué c'est qu'il adore
réfléchir très très longtemps oui après
il peut réfléchir longtemps sais pas
pourquoi alain en fait à linverse
d'autres joueurs en fait il est
tellement dans la perfection en une
partie aux candidats où il réfléchit pas
ce qu'ils trouvent pas le gain en une
ligne qui fait quinze coups et puis il
avait une heure conduit minutes et il se
retrouve avec 10 secondes ouais c'est
contre rajab afssa
non c'était contre job job ah oui tu es
en championnat d'europe désolé parce
qu'en fait il a fait un choix similaire
oui contre adjamé superbe partie
d'ailleurs
super party et du coup toi je sais pas
si c'est un sujet quelques parler là en
attendant de voir comment l'ouverture se
développe mais il ya l'équipe de france
bientôt c'est toi le sélectionneur a
sélectionné j'imagine alireza de base et
maxime vachier lagrave comment tu as tu
appris le refus des joueurs c'est non
mais après c'était un peu compliqué pour
alireza il a un programme surchargé
donc c'est vrai que ça tombait mal c'est
quand ces
tournois et qu'il aurait fait jouer
peut-être de trois mois d'affilée
non-stop avec la possibilité aussi du
match de championnat du monde des
rallyes qui arrive assez rapidement en
mars quand même même si ça peut paraître
loin en réalité ça à ses proches après
voilà après aussi c'est un
voyage
le compliqué quand tu es un joueur
professionnel
un peu plus de chance de tomber malade
d'école en un grand nord n'est pas un
pays européen donc pour certains qui
sont plus fragiles au niveau de
l'estomac avec des gros tournois un peu
avant et après c'est pas facile et
surtout que les chaleurs sont
au dessus de 50 degrés ouais on peut
arriver si je crois que j'ai vu on peut
arriver je vais parler même avec maxime
ont parié sur 51 52 degrés mais là ils
ont battu les records donc voilà donc
c'était évidemment je pense que on
aurait fait l'effort si l'équipe était
au complet
partir du moment où on a commencé à
avoir un peu de monde en moins c'est
difficile pour les autres ça c'est un
peu faire un château de cartes château
de cartes bon c'est comme ça apprendra
une belle équipe et on va essayer de
faire quelque chose d'intéressant quels
sont tes objectifs du coup avec avec
cette équipe tu vises quoi tu vises
je pense qu'on peut espérer un top 10
ouais atteint ce qu'on a comme une belle
équipe avec que des joueurs au dessus de
avec avec mathieu aussi morisi oxyjeunes
état est à jules qui en pleine bourre
j'ai eu qu'un petit bourg fraises qui a
super bien joué au top 16 un nul contre
n'importe quel joueur sur la planète
il a fait nul contre maxime avec les
noirs donc oui s'il fait une contre
maxime des clés noires
et puis on a maxime lagarde très très
bon aussi quoi donc en fait le le le
les olympiades ça joue souvent sur les
deux dernières rondes ce que tu peux
être donc une fois il ya en 2016 on
avait
quand je jouais dans l'équipe on a été
très mal partie est perdue contre
l'uruguay en jouait le costa rica table
70 kw à pionnat les quatre derniers
matchs et ont fini 7e le tournoi était
vraiment pas beau et puis à la fin tu
vois là après on a joué deux fois la
table une pour finir on perd on finit
11e
je pense que voilà un tournoi comme ça
dans le top 10 en étant vers le haut ce
serait pas mal un bon résultat déjà on
verra quel sur quelle quelle place on
sera au départ il n'y aura pas les
russes mais bon je pense pas comme pas
mal de belges équipe est le championnat
le prochain championnat d'europe du coup
c'est l'an prochain ouais 2003 est donc
là tu espères je pense qu'on aura on
aura la grosse équipe et espère viser 1
médaille d'or ouais va clairement
l'objectif à là on a tout pour tout pour
y arriver
ah ben si tu as ta fille rundschau max
et emme et max et jules qui a explosé on
a maxime la gare on à fressines et on a
même trop de joueurs maintenant pour
l'équipe une est encore un casse tête
entre deux ans la première équipe
c'était très compliqué et du crif y ait
quelqu'un
c'est un choix dit est ce que tu as des
résultats par mme sur l'olympiade là que
tu vas jouer dans un mois et demi
suivant comme ça tu vas voir on va dire
que tu vas voir quatre joueurs pour
trois places visuellement les prochaines
fois donc pour rappeler battu avoir
acquis que les gens connaissent bien ici
laurent frayssinet que les gens
connaissent bien aussi maxime lagarde
que les gens connaissent bien aussi et
jules moussard du coup j'ai même envie
de dire jules en ce moment il est
peut-être un peu il a un peu pris le le
l'a peu fait l'écart mais du coup à des
résultats de laurent ou de maxime
lagarde ça pourra jouer si tant est
qu'ils font vraiment gros tournois as
oui bien sûr après bon voilà c'est plus
d'un an et demi avant les championnats
d'europe ah oui c'est assez aussi loin
je le voyais a souvent ça en octobre on
en aurait lancé trop loin je trop loin
mais après ça donne une petite idée de
comment on joue par équipe ça se passe
voilà laurent brun on le joue beaucoup
moins aux échecs maintenant enfin maxime
mais allez on voit que des qui réjouit
il est présent oui oui puis il a un
profil qui peut être intéressant par
rapport à imagine toi ce que tu vois un
joueur solide c'est clair qu'on a
beaucoup de feux follets dans l'équipe
on n'a que des ailiers quoi il faudrait
du numéro 6 quoique jugent ces derniers
temps sur ces parties où elle avait joué
ici et non j'ai passé de dembélé à un
bon numéro 6 k way il perd beaucoup
moins il n'avait pas perdu depuis
quarante parties non non il est devenu
il a il a pris en solidité et non
franchement il a passé un cap il peut
même peut-être viser les 2007 un non
plus si les
aidant il est souvent avec maxime et
lille dans un cercle ou vraiment il ya
de très bons joueurs et donc pour heil
en progression en progression constante
c'est vrai que ça peut nous faire 3-1 et
à peut-être aussi on l'espère pour lui
et pour nous marquant qui peut par
conviction et à n'importe quel moment et
il va chercher un peu qu'on l'a
sélectionné c'est pour cela il a eu une
année c'est pas sa meilleure année
c'est vrai qu'il ya toujours des petits
capteurs optiques ap dès 2004 2005 c'est
comme un gros cap il le passe et repasse
en dessous il fait un peu le yoyo
et donc à cette barrière à franchir pour
aller après chercher celle de demi et
après la culbute un peu comme jules qui
passent justement là cette barrière 26
26 52 ans resté très longtemps entre en
dessous de 26 et 26 ans il reste
peut-être cinq ans et là on sent qu'il a
passé un cap chacun sa barrière il faut
je pense qu'il faut aider marquant à
passer cette barrière en étant
sélectionné ça lui donner de la
motivation
donc la prendre et c'est clairement un
joueur que tu as tu eu marquant qui
arrive à karachi la 15 ans actuellement
ouais je crois qu'il vaut h 15 donc
c'est un joueur clairement que tu a
sélectionné la pour pour l'avenir que tu
aurais pas forcément pris site avait eu
24 mois
oui cent pour cent sûr qu'il n'aurait
pas été pris il n'est pas encore au
niveau des autres donc là c'est un pari
est un pari sur l'avenir et sur et sur
la formation c'est cool dehors tu en
parles avec topps avec les la question
revient très souvent on imagine ah ouais
c'est normal on s'intéresse tous
forcément l'équipe de france comme dans
tous les sports en fait et donc c'était
cool de pouvoir te demander en plus on a
maxime dans le chat tu vois qui nous met
des petits d'eptica crocs quand même à
tout moment
la sélection de cornette aussi c'est un
pari sur l'avenir et oui d'ailleurs
section de cordes end en voilà c'est le
seul à seul sur laquelle on est parvenu
oui belle action de cornette c'était
donc il ya eu pas mal de désistement et
du coup après il y avait plusieurs
joueurs qui étaient candidats pour cet
attentat est très vite fait le choix de
prendre marquant et après l'es7 c'est
cette
cinquième place
voilà moi mathieu voilà je pense que par
équipe c'est un super joueur et je pense
qu'on y joue des joueurs plus fort que
lui bon
ça après pas
voilà plus facilité quand tu es content
plus fait extraordinaire rien mais ça a
eu bon sens sans annoncer la composition
voilà on allie sera peut-être plus tôt
vers le haut pour essayer de faire
chatouiller des joueurs il avait battu
harry krishna mais exactement ce que
j'allais dire il joue harry krishna à
2700 avec les noirs il a pas de problème
et du coup ils provoquent les mecs a
plongé en fait tu étais content moi tu
es le jour où il a appris sa sélection
alors bien sûr les détails que j'étais
en train de faire un duo était comme un
gamin il y croyait il m'a dit tom je
reçois prêt lequel j'y crois pas ouais
mais ouais c'était il était avec moi ce
matin là ont discuté ensemble était
comme un gage lui parler d'autres trucs
tu vois qui me paraissait mois plus
important
j'ai ouï c'est ça je parlais des sujets
encore au dessus tu vas entre guillemets
et je réussissais pas le déconnecter de
sa boîte mail
était il était comme un gamin c'est
super la posture du jeu n'est pas
sélectionné parce que voilà c'est un
très proche tout il y avait tout le
monde a été sélectionnée il ya eu même
des listes ont été fait avant lui
d'autres joueurs qui ont refusé
donc tous les joueurs qui peuvent être
cités ont été aussi refusé enfin fait le
choix de pas venir donc
très content pour lui et puis et puis en
plus voilà c'est un ami donc c est ce
que dans ce genre de deux cas quand un
joueur comme ça qui est qui est très bon
réputé un bon théoriquement est-ce que
parfois quand tu te tues tu quand il est
sur la touche quand il est remplaçant il
peut aussi aider les autres joueurs dans
la préparation comment ça se passe où
est-ce qu'il se repose complètement
pas normalement il se repose un mais bon
après
je vois apparemment bien marc andriat tu
vas parraitre un exemple simple on sait
en plus qu'ils ont travaillé ensemble
est ce que tu as un jour où tu dis bon
mathieu la wii sur l'art quand il joue
mais du coup vous connaissez bien et
vite à l'adversaire non mais c'est ce
qu'on avait dit avec écrire ou de jallet
revient il avait il avait commencé à
donner des conseils dont les camps ont
commencé à jouer le titre ouais c'est
bien orienté la prépa de nos joueurs on
a quand même on à mathieu collette
laurent frayssinet on a quand même des
joueurs qui même par une seule petite
phrase peuvent guider sur quoi faire la
tête de deux cracks deux beaux
théoriciens
et imagine si tabac qui dans l'équipe en
plus pour une autre compétition là tu as
3 à 3 monstres théorique c'est vrai
qu'en france on a on a des excellents
théoricien on avait vu l'ado commentaire
là mathieu on à laurent on abat qui m'a
quand même d'aider des joueurs qui sont
réputés pour leurs connaissances en
france en hollande école
école de l'apprentissage la théorie du
travail
ouais non c'est vrai que c'est pas
forcément je ne citerai pas la france en
nos extérieurs mais bon on est
probablement derrière les rues ils sont
encore une multitude de joueurs mais on
est quand même assez
basses et bien quoi bon du coup ça a
joué ça a joué alors sa page le grand
chose sajoo et rock qui on prend des
quatre cavaliers prend des quatre
étudiants on n'en sait pas plus on sait
pas plus un bon pour répondre à une
question qui a été un peu calé le
quel est l'intérêt de qu'est ce que
doivent faire les blancs les noirs dans
la catalane en fait le principe c'est
les blancs vont jouer tout sur ce fou
j'ai deux c'est un peu le pendant de ton
fou du dragon voilà exactement et donc
les noirs leur but c'est de faire vivre
ce fou s'est vite
souvent
ils n'arrivent pas à le faire vivre mais
ils ont un pion de plus en mangeant c4
et en protégeant ses pions c4 il ya un
pion de plus mais est souvent des
compensations stratégique et par contre
qu'on a le schéma la partie prend ces
quatre là me prends ces quatre là il n'y
a pas de plan de plus l'on voit que le
fou g2 du coup donne un petit avantage
aux blancs donc là souvent les noirs
doivent être très précis pour vite faire
jouer ce fou c86 direct failli perdre en
fait il n'arrive pas parce que les
blancs on se développe et qui a essayé
trois fois f4 tour c'est un tour d un et
on punir les le manque de développement
de noir tout capelle près parce que pour
le moment bon nous on sait pas ce qui se
passe donc on essaye on cherche un peu
des sujets tu voi alors il est souvent
il ya souvent secoué que 5 1 qui rôde
eux
toujours dangereux parce que fait 5
ouvre un peu encore plus les cases
blanches pour les blancs on voit que des
5 devient une belle qu'à une belle case
f5 aussi mais le problème de f5 c'est
qu'il faut bien savoir où on va ce qui à
mon avis n'est pas du tout le cas là
pour caruana parce que si tu l'as far et
des f-5 il faut vraiment être très
précieux pas très précis parce que là
évidemment fou prend f5 dame prend 25
c'est la cata exactement certes on a
perdu notre fou c'est 8 mai les cases
blanches on
[Musique]
sait on a toutes les cases blanches
dont claouey et des princes et 4 dames
français 4 depuis tout à l'heure ils
refusent de le faire c'est pas forcément
le meilleur tempo comme on l'est encore
il ya encore puis on comprend que l'on
me comprendra me prend 1,5
cavaye f5 et qui a une idée à faire
mais c'est très concret en fait
ces options 17
je déteste jouer contre les catalanes
avec les noirs
agréable et c'est un des trucs enfin
j'ai jamais aimé en fait c'est peut-être
qu'il esquisse qui m'a le plus dégoûtés
j'ai en fait il y avait laurent
frayssinet qui avait montré une par une
idée à lui ou du coup c'était toi qui
avait le contrôle je tu vois pas un
petit peu montrée peut-être juste un peu
avant
c'est un fait avec la dame en c2 alors
dame ces deux c6 le tir hoc
cavalier c'est dans sa classe et à
5k et c3 et la baie st
une idée qui a été jouée qui était un
peu plus à la mode qui du coup ouvre un
peu le jeu pour les
pour les noir et en fait c'est toi qui
je jouais fou à seaska et ses six tours
b 8 tours s'est vite et donc tu inverses
le schéma de te faire dominer c'est très
très très marrant parce que quand j'ai
dit ah ben là j'arrive pas à jouer
contre les catalanes il m'a dit
exactement enfin même conseil safe un tu
vois moi c'est pour du blitz à richard
est parti donc c'est plus sérieux mais
il m'a dit n'hésitez pas envoyez un pion
avec b5 faire d'anne decis car c'est ici
c'est exactement liées au lieu de temps
merdé
moi je me suis mis à jouer ça je trouve
il m'a parlé d'une partie en équipe de
france en plus qu'il a joué avec vous là
contre peut-être maurice
entre l'ukrainien l'ukrainien l'acquis
et 2007 jen cauwet lui avait fait très
mal mais les cinq qui ont prendre un
bébé si s'il m'avait dit tu imagines
intel ne connaissais pas
mais oui c'est sympa quand même plan et
laurent du coup il le fait avec à cinq
écoutes j'ai peut-être j'ai peut-être
vous prendre l'idée j'essaierai ah bah
c'est pas un secret donc ouais c'est
sympa en fait ce que tu files l'option
mais au moins tu vois tu sortais pièce
tu vas tu kiffes il a joué car alice et
six en attendant qu'est c6 hockey est-ce
que ça va jouer tempo dit on va se
remettre grande cam
sabots un petit peu d'eau
et laissez la queen avant ça pour une
tu le connais quand il boit de l'eau ça
veut dire quelque chose ou pas le temps
d à ce niveau de connaissances alireza
là pour encore
face on s'y prend plus de 4 ou 5 minutes
n'est pas s'ils s'y connait il va y va
cliquer là
ça peut être la ligne principale ça
c'est sur
c'est quoi les options de façon c'est
carré de choix sur laquelle processes
swaptions prend des 5
je regardais quoi en premier qu'est ce
qui te casting avait planqué france et 6
puis on prend
et maintenant essayer de
faire jouer ce fou donc pourquoi pas des
trois fous b2k et des deux comme ça
bon en fait je n'aime pas trop jouer
contre cette structure c6
d56 trouve très très solide pour les
noirs dernièrement on appelle ça andy
murray andy murray contre le fou ça
bloque complètement temps fou donc moi
de base je jouerai puis on prend des
cinq pour t'ouvrir le photographe donc
là deux choix soit il reprend avec le
pion en dessin qu'elle en est un pion
isolé ça ça a l'air bien on a un bon set
up ça c'est très bien pour les bleus
surtout que la dame en d3 est très utile
par rapport à la dame en c2 et du
college à placer l epa sur la colonne
s'est roulé noir orange le tour c'est 8
est donc là elle est idéalement placé
donc l'appui on prend des cinq n'est pas
envisageable plutôt qu'à rallier prend
cac et prend mais là maintenant on peut
prendre ces 6es du coup on n'a plus du
tout le monde dit murray pas du tout
pareil là on a la structure similaire à
l'oeil droit mais deux îlots contre un
îlot allèles dame là c'est un peu le on
dit après sa blessure quoi la blessure à
la hanche
on dit fletcher là du coup c'est pat fry
et à la fameuse voilà une très belle
case qui est importante à connaître ces
cinq points à 2 c5 et c4 pour nos
cavaliers pour notre cavalier afin de
préparer un plan avec le four b2 les
tours en centre bien et c'est donc il va
peut-être jouer qu'ils avaient libéré
quatre intermédiaires québec atteint à
l'air d'être le coup
et sur quoi du coup ils profitent un peu
de cette dame alors de quel côté il par
là je dirais dame b 3
c'est toujours pas mal l'ademe paris six
cavaliers b prend des cinq
tours d un à lectoure bien attention 4
ça c'est dangereux ça déjà ça je déteste
ça c'est exactement ce que je déteste
le truc c'est que tu sais jamais en fait
ça se peut que ça aille avec line pour
les noirs seraient tous pressés mais ça
se peut que ça aille pas du tout et ne
sait pas jouer un demba cissé et
souffrir là c'est trop dur non ça s'est
fait ramener qui gagne facile
et ça en plus ça peut ça peut durer
vraiment longtemps ce genre de parties
tuent peu souffert même si tu réussis xi
a bien joué tu peux prendre vingt trente
quarante cinquante coups c'est en a
marre avant d'avoir commencé donc
s'éprend des cinq mon cavalier b4 quand
même
dame b3 s que ici est une autre option
tu vois la turbine est donnent eux 5 wen
la céline de turbines atteint
lifeway et nous commence à nous sortir
ça carrossée qu'il est costaud
ça faut avoir envie hein mais bon pareil
un tueur et ouvre donc à et ses deux
coups normale et la malle et b prend des
cinq donc avec l'idée de jouer peut-être
fou aussi ce rapidement
il rentre là dedans en fait
par tous les pions
ouais il faut avoir envie de rentrer là
dedans ouais parce qu'avec les noirs tu
as quand même deux pions de moi et il
faut être très costaud
il faut être très costaud
après ce qui est dommage c'est que
même c'est pas le principal ali reza il
avait été ils avaient même connu des
coups dans les dents les dans les trois
premières parties qui était qu'ils
n'étaient pas les premiers et là le
cavalier c6
l'a surpris en fait
et il n'a pas le cas pas le coup
en fait tu réfléchis t'as pas le choix
n'a absolument pas le choix ouais mais
il peut se mettre à réfléchir une demi
heure on s'est pas trop pourquoi moment
il va jouer vite avant 1h 40 il a joué
encore douze minutes
petit paris ça commence ça commence mal
joué et préfère la tunisie va réfléchir
longtemps
j'ai pas réussi à tenir
j'ai lancé un premier petit peu après et
toi ce que tu as bien joué au top 12 du
coût ouais j'ai bien joué j'ai pas fait
en top12 extraordinaire mais j'ai fait
trois victoires et 6 nuls
c'est vrai que j'étais retombé très très
bas en fin 2021 quasiment de près des
2500 ouais ça faisait longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas vu un donc là j'ai repris à
saillé vingtaine de points ça commence à
être un peu mieux j'ai eu un peu de mal
avec les blancs où je suis pas encore
pas du tout assez bien préparé un
gros problème au niveau des prépas
on a joué et j'ai dû jouer cette partie
contre mathieu qui a été quand même très
compliqué à jouer en plus la jouer à
fond mais tu as joué à fond si en fait à
chaque fois qu'on joue et nos deux clubs
ont demandé à voir les noirs parce que
c'est très problématique
je vous montre contre 1 partout et
surtout un pote et surtout qu'à la fin
voilà c'est mathieu sinon je vois tout
le temps c'est tout le temps à bordeaux
dès qu'on a une idée des convois une
partie sur internet et à le petit groupe
whatsapp le pivot bois de cinq matches
et nous envoient tient les copains
regarder ça
j'ai travaillé ça pendant trois jours
bla bla bla moi je suis pas dans le
groupe mais je récupère les
conversations après une brouille
heureusement il me fait 1-1 le nectar le
meilleur de ce qui vous a montré il me
leur montre après on met du coup voilà
c'est donc c'est très très dur mais bon
voilà à la base qu'on a fait le choix
que je joue cet échiquier moi j'espérais
une page de mathieu il y avait quand
même quatre choix possible
beaucoup de chance que match et niçois
pas ce que vus les autres joueurs elle
vu la forme des autres joueurs on
pouvait espérer que d'autres et les
noirs et que
m'a tuer les blancs avec les blancs
mathieu voilà j'ai déjà parlé mais c'est
quasiment 2700 le père fait avec les
noirs c'est 2400 cas vraiment un gap
incroyable et surtout avec les blancs
voient ils auraient pu hélas pu très
bien gagner et une partie
donc on a fait ce choix là donc là le
jour balla le matin voilà donc à mazet
cornette barre
donc la premier problème que jouer face
à mathieu mathieu koné tout mon
répertoire
et il le connaît mieux que toi il le
connaît mieux que moi en plus on met un
peu de sagesse que déjà on travaille
ensemble même parfois on nage et quand
j'ai fait des gros tournois je pas
d'europe je les prie en tant que seconde
en donc pas vraiment et c'est encore
plus quoi trouver des amendes dans le
dans le répertoire assez lui leur
répertoire
et voilà j'ai essayé de jouer un premier
coup je joue très rarement et qui du
coup nous amène sur un peu sur une
position
on n'avait jamais travaillé c était le
cas et donc tu as pu vous avez pu jouer
un plus je venais de partie c'était au
début c'était bizarre puis après on a
fait ce combat ou fait c'est un peu
embrouillé dès le début j'ai un peu ce
sera fait la partie et c'était marrant
c'était sur nos forces
stratégiquement il s'est embrouillé il a
fait un fr et amis un cavalier qui avait
pas de case et
c'est quasiment un avantage décisif
positionnelle angers j'avais tout et
puis là je me suis dit tiens on va ça y
est c'est la folie maintenant je vais me
matter quoi
et en fait j'ai déjà raté une ressource
typique de mathieu gones il alors on en
achète il m'envoie tourache 8 il remet
le ronge et 8 c'est lui qui matent
typique typique et du coup il ya le
changement qui s'effectue et là je suis
en gros souffrance et je trouve un truc
à cavaler h1 qui tient la position je
pense que je pense qu'il ya une petite
erreur due
capitaine adverse
ouais
donc ça aurait pu faire tourner jeunes
ans après c'est une petite erreur parce
que dans le match il était bien vrai on
imaginait mal voilà notre position à
mathieu et shauna mais connaissant le
rapport de force était plus une position
pour mathieu quoi et c'était très chaud
la position tactiquement il en avait
partout où je vais sacrifier ce dont je
n'étais pas en confiance et puis surtout
le capitan fin on voit que la position
s'est inversée moi j'étais en train de
dominer la position et la du coup
j'étais en train de scier de la sauver
donc a eu ce nul et qui finalement nous
faire nous permet d'être champion une
nouvelle fois et ça faisait 51 matches
sans défaite pour pour ton équipe ouais
ouais
oui voilà gozzoli était très bien ce
moment-là fargo de l'iss était en train
de tourner en rond on fait nul
1-1 pile puis c'est arrivé pile au bon
pour toi en fait tu reste très
compliquée donc ouais top-12 j'étais
assez content surtout mais surtout c'est
un lacet un truc par équipe donc on
n'est pas là pour rien c'est bien ne pas
perdre 30 points ou et c'est bien en
gagner 30 mais surtout ce qui compte
c'est d'être champion es-tu coup sûr mon
takkal classement là je vais être pas
loin de 535 donc j'aimerais bien voilà
je vais roger loin de temps ouais mais
c'est loin de son niveau normal entre
guillemets encore très loin mais bon
c'est vrai qu'on voit que beaucoup de
joueurs là c'est ce qu vide a coûté bout
notre équipe par exemple à bijoux hier
on était tous à moins 100 points par
rapport à un autre pic et ouais donc
bacrot naïditch rôle stein qui était de
1785 25 80
donc c'est clair que ils sont passés où
ces points laissant partir je suis passé
en inde ils sont partis en partie dans
des soirées
c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de gens qui
ont perdu des points et c'est son parti
un peu en
collecter tout sac et comment il
s'appelle il ya le yanni mal j'ai vu qui
fait une remontée fantastique il est
numéro 1 mondial moins de 18 ans ouais
alors il vient d'avoir 19 là donc il a
reperdu 100 litres et oui les kills et
de miro 2 mondial moindre affirme
incroyable moi je le voyais pas du tout
aussi fort moi je vais jouer ya deux ans
là il m'a battue il est passé grand
maître sur cette partie mais il
progresse à une vitesse je sais que je
ne le voyais pas du tout arrivé je me
suis complètement planté et maintenant
je me dis peut même être 27 50 voire
même plus ses
places bien les pièces sur les belles
cases c'est assez propre puis travail
j'ai l'impression que ça ils travaillent
beaucoup et ils jouent beaucoup il
travaille beaucoup après il parle très
fort et un peu
page pas fan fan - oui mais bon regarde
hikaru pendant longtemps n'a pas été
finalement il a fait il fait kiffer il
ne sait pas qu'il a fait c'est qui fait
quand même beaucoup de choses pour les
échecs même si on peut aimer ou ne pas
aimer le style oh non mais tu est un
super joueur il peut s'agit les jeunes
encore un quand même le est très jeune
peu s'assagir avec l'âge
tout cas il a bien progressé
je m'inquiète un peu là pour pour ali
reza qui qui joue pas du tout je te
propose qu'on fasse un tout petit tour
des stades allez pour qu'on voie un peu
ce qui se passe on peut on va faire un
peu dans l'ordre va les voir ricard où
aller
car ou hikaru qui hier
a raté quand même quelque chose
pour les
voiles à l'ordi on a notre petit notre
petit evan zélandaise même visuellement
qui est pas content et c'est vrai que
quand tu vois
là en fait dans ses positions l'idée
c'est d'avoir tu as perdu ton trou blanc
donc les cases blanches et finis ton
seul point fort c'est cette caste c5 à
la casse et 5 et protéger trois fois et
surtout que les noirs vont eux mêmes
faire ces cinq pour t'ouvrir fasse
paraître léger avantage mais avec si en
réalité donc bon après voilà ça peut
être une prépa avec des idées et de
faire placer le cavalier en b3 et
assez voilà c'est pas avoir tout cas je
dirais quand même petit petit petit plus
pour ding petite victoire de l'ouverture
pour les noix ding peut-être que s'il
gagne il va réussir à se débloquer ce
qui semble fort en fait tu manques de la
conclusion attention adding s'ils
gagnent une partie il peut se réveiller
radjabov rapporte on annonce et
une nulle
et en fait
ça vient d'où ce truc là
il a rejoint la sienne est battu à la
variante dont parlait mathieu en pré
life la pagerie food et 3 il a joué dam
des trois îles des trois dames g3 wave
et connaît bien ça il en a parlé aussi
web
le niveau temps et donc là les deux
joueurs et surtout les noirs sont en
plein dans leur pré paul
attention
radjabov version ras djir j'ai peur
qu'ils finissent par craquer en fait là
il a hélas il va typiquement dans le
ce que cherche
rapporte donc ça pourrait être dangereux
et la dernière qu'on n'a pas vu c'est
celle de duda
contre yann nepomniachi
la cedh hudak irréfléchie et ce à
commencer par carrier f3
ça joue à ce genre de réty
ouais bon là c'est la partie la plus
calme bon petit plus blanc tout léger
souple et noir son coin tard de
développement ares peut à tout moment
faire j'ai quatre coloris cibc attention
très attention avec les noirs c'est pas
facile
bon à voir et à lire les a joués dont
convard la on ait gagné mon pari un
ouais t'as gagné ton premier premier
pari du jour écoute tu réussis tous là
je commence à être en confiance il n'y a
pas eu de problèmes techniques il a pris
en d5 pas tous les bons paris ça sent la
victoire pour ali reza l'annoncé annoncé
il ya trois jours je vous envoie des
textos un oui le texto est envoyée
j'arrive il attend la victoire il attend
le capitaine pour gagner
j'annonce que s'il gagne tu seras donc
après le tennis à bâle a en plus nous on
n'est pas loin c'est clair on n'est pas
loin du tennis
je ne vais pas chanter encore on va
attendre un peu
ça va venir ça va venir n'arrive pas ce
qu'on trouve être son accueil
sa forme en compte a pas vu sur le title
d'ailleurs ouais j'aurais mais c'est
vrai que c'était tous les mardis là et
c'est sa tombe et c'est pas bien ouais
c'est pas bien tombé mais là on va avoir
de nouvelles de nouvelles choses à la
rentrée de belles choses à voir arriver
à voir des trucs très sympa je ne peux
pas encore en parler parce que tu as
comme va faire va faire des annonces
mais il va y avoir du nouveau tournoi
qui vont plaire s'ils vont pas tomber le
mardi
est donc plus on prend des 5
donc on avait vu cavalli b 4-1 qui
semblait être le coup parce qu'on avait
dit que sur cavale et prend des cinq
cavaliers français 6 la structure était
trop moche ouais ainsi les structures
dit l'oim ses classiques trois îlots
compte deux îlots
très dangereux pour les noirs
trop dangereux
ça c'est long et pénible pour les noirs
ce genre de position il a forcément joué
cavalli b4 je pense je vois pas d'autres
options et b4 pas rien un cahier prend
des cats on peut montrer un peu cac et
prend des cadres dan franck avait prend
des 5
par exemple jusqu'à l'essai 3 qui avait
prend ces trois dames prend ces trois là
on a le schéma du voilà de ce qu'on veut
éviter avec l'ailé noire c'est de ce
fameux flux c8 qui n'arrive pas survivre
face à ce flou g2c le petit tom tempo de
plus pour les blancs donc ça c'est même
si ses traits symétriques c'est quand
même très compliqué parce que cette tour
peut jamais venu en b 8 se fait attaquer
le pion à 7 est faible aussi
ça c'est généralement une torture alors
évidemment que ça peut faire nul mais
c'est 7 7 heures de torture
enfin bien où il veut il peut pas
vouloir rentrer là dedans
après qui a et b cattin sait on l'a vu
un cfc vraiment une très fort par tir
sur du show quoi il faut partir sur sur
du très concret
après tu peux l'avoir par élimination
ces écarts ou qui disait sur ses lives
qui jouait beaucoup par élimination
même bien qu'on est au rsa ça marche pas
ça marche pas donc ça ça marche quoi un
gamin 14 ans classé 15e déchire au
tennis
des classes et combien maintenant 5-5 6
ha ouais tu montes
montella début j'ai passé 5 et donc
normalement la langue tu joues tu auras
un premier tour facile ça se passe
comment au tennis en fait les premiers
tours tu joues un joueur qui est ils
font tout pour tes deux matches en
général donc ton premier tour tu es tu
joue en contre perf ok je joue quelqu'un
qui est moins bien classée que toi ok 15
1 15 1 qui a battu le 15 en gros oui oui
et après deuxième tour tu joues
quelqu'un qui rentre dans le tournoi qui
fait son premier tour lui il joue en
contre perf bac j'avais un père et du
coup là tu joues un 4/6 est-ce que tu
qu'on peut on fait souvent des
parallèles avec le tennis etc est-ce que
c'est frustrant quand tu vas jouer un
tournoi parce que nos échecs on n'a pas
l'habitude de jouer ce type de tournoi
sardou quand on va en prendre moi ça
dure une semaine on sait qu'on va jouer
une semaine on joue toutes les parties
là au tennis toile par exemple tu es
venu ici pour jouer ce tournoi est-ce
que c'est frustrant de se dire que ben
dimanche potentiellement tu joues à 9
heures on sait pas quelle heure tu vois
tu joues dimanche 9h peut-être que
dimanche 10h30 le tournoi pour toi est
finie
et après par rapport aux échecs quand
même aux échecs quand t'es pas en forme
bah tu dois rester comme dix joueurs à
l'endroit où tu es pas en forme alors
que la
voilà c'était pas en forme bon après si
t'es pas en forme et que tu perds bon
c'est pas grave si tu es en forme et
qu'il joue contre quelqu'un qui est un
ancien pro et qui a enfin par l'ancien
pro mais bon quelqu'un qui a très peur
car il faut classement un peu embêtant
et après ça ce qu'on pense au fil de
l'année et à des parfois tu as des tours
plus facile il t'a détour - dieu enfin
plus difficiles etc
aignan moi j'aime bien le principe après
c'est vrai que là bas non plus le niveau
monte - je vais traverser le tableau
dire que quand j'étais
en bon je pouvais gagner 6 7 matches là
tu l'as tu souffres plus à maintenant
les mecs c'est comme ces chauffards qui
sont
soit qu'ils sont des anciens très très
bons joueurs et qui sont redescendus du
coup il n'y a pas pire un affaire soit
c'est des joueurs qui sont des jeunes
qui sont en train d'essayer de passer
semi pro
c'est lui le jeune l'a46 qui m'a mis
zéro et 0 là c'est un semi pro
sapât pas réellement nettement plus fort
ouais alors après j'étais arrivé je
m'étais trompé de
de philosophie sur la partie j'étais
arrivé en pensant que je pouvais gagner
le match
j'étais je pensais que je jouais mal et
en fait c'est lui qui jouait trop bien
d'accord ce qui peut arriver aussi aux
échecs parfois quand tu penses alors
clair fois j'ai joué un monstre kima
emile 0 et 1 ère fois et je m'étais dit
bon objectif de jeu finalement je perd 6
4 7 6 en trois heures de match et est en
fait j'ai une mentalité à chaque fois
c'était je parle
j'avais eu ce problème une fois en
russie aux échecs quand j'avais joué un
mec qui était classé 23 50 donc j'arrive
à la partie 23 50 avec les blancs tu as
c'est à la fin qu'on voulait vraiment
mieux si bon allez je vais lui m on va
jouer un truc bien compliqué il faut une
sicilienne on va bien ouvrir moi je veux
bien tactique je lui faire très mal
le sort de la partie le mec me met 28
coup avec les blancs je sors j'appelle
la dass et à moscou et tout et j arrête
parce que j'ai aujourd'hui je perds
contre 1,2358 mais 28 coups à jouer bien
en plus moi je n'ai pas perdu 25 parties
d'affilée avec les blancs et là je sais
pas là tu sens qu'il ya un truc parce
que j'avais l'air bien et me dit moi le
nom du gars et là je dis le nom du gars
evan williams et il vient de vendre 200
250 points elo en fait le même
et du coup même même impression en fait
une partie très mauvaise et tu comprend
qu'en fait vous êtes avaient la mauvaise
approche avec joie à 25 80 je dis oui
oui on veut car ces cinq élèves trois
des six hommes fous b 5 h avec monsieur
très solide on va pas faire des quatre
quand même oui oui c'est la même salle
aménagée en fait à charge tout le
prochain ça change tout et et ça change
sa perception ton propre jeu où seraient
donc il a joué cavalier prend des cinq
fabiano wake est la ligne la plus
humaine donc et c3 son idée c'est fou et
pour taper la dame est sûre dame c4
pendant ces 3 probablement baisser et du
coup c'est les blancs qui ont la
mauvaise structure mais pas si simple
c'est parce qu'il ya le pion bessette
qu'humainement à une maintenance et le
c'est le meilleur choix pour les noirs
donc là par exemple si on peut prendre
une position rigolote s'ils jouent damas
cinq tours d1 dames français
troistorrents c'est trop ces trois tours
bien et blanc un pion de moins mais la
position noir est compliqué quand même
il ya ce fou ces huit toujours le
dilemme de cette position qui ne peut
pas bouger je n'aime pas prendre l'avion
c'est qu'il peut pas bouger
en soit généralement les noirs essaye de
rendre enfin deux
espèrent que les bras ils essayent de
jouer à 5 à 4 tours à 6
obliger un peu fou prend bessette a
récupéré le point fr nul mais bon
c'est loin d'être fait on va te faire à
4 x 3 ça c'est mieux pour les bleus
c'est sûr
après bon ça c'est plat quand même c'est
pas forcément la ligne qu'on espérait
pour la partie alors peut-être que kbc 3
je pense qu'il ne jouera pas caler ses
trois parce que quand même c'est très
très très plat très plein
tour d un cours d un
homme normal qui
donne sur la colonne des
fers fou 17 pour donner le
lecavalier jouer à
l'option plus tôt alors ce genre de truc
rsa ya c'est trop fort pour les enfants
ce que si réfléchir c'est ce dont on
parle
depuis tout à l'heure avec sable messi
réussit à mettre le four en c6 s'est
immédiatement et galway aucun problème
d'ailleurs on retarde de points pour le
blanc
et il peut aussi jouer parfois sur cette
idée avec b4y et b4 prise prisée car
lycées 2 faire attention à ça aussi
quand le caribéen et pas développer
pas facile de comprendre comment je
voulais avantage ici est-ce qu'on peut
jouer davantage même d'ailleurs
res pas facile hein sûr je pense aussi
qu'ils manquent d'expérience dans ses
positions
quand même pas son
style il est concentré en tout cas
car kühl
à ce serait embêtant que ce soit de
nouvelles parties avec les blancs où il
réussit vraiment pas du tout a infligé
une pression à l'adversaire
ce que contredit d'ailleurs on va passer
on va pas se cacher c'était quand même
relativement ratés comme partie même
s'il n'y a pas eu de grosse erreur et si
aujourd'hui on a un peu le même scénario
étrange 1 ils étaient tellement forts au
grand suisse et
acheteurs peuvent forcément le même
niveau
c'est vraiment du le gratin du gratin
ce qu'il avait fait tellement mal 20
suta sous sa direction en équipe de
france championnat d'europe on l'avait
suivi s'étaient toutes les parties
étaient incroyables pas de pas de pause
sajoo est fort tout le temps et là on a
on a l'impression d'avoir perdu
l'impression de l'avoir perdue avec avec
vous c'est dans quelle ville déjà
[Musique]
ministres
sont souvent way to petite ville
cattez
ouais c'est dommage il était tellement
en forme il avait joué le grand suisse
de très bonne facture
et là on arrive on le on le retrouve pas
après il peut comme comme tu le disais
aussi à la préparation en face est plus
forte et du coup il a passé position
aussi oui bien sûr alors s'il avait
comme des joueurs du top 10 avec des
cheveux gris de choc mamediarov il est
le cas juana suisse ouais mais qu'à
roanne elle avait perdu finalement ouais
ouais c'est sûr jamais fait la
différence contre les autres ouais mam
et la partie qu'il a gagné le
championnat d'europe elle et elle est
magnifique mais ça aurait été individuel
m'améliorer prévenus l'un peu plus tôt
dans la partie
donc au final c'est vrai que ces joueurs
là il aurait pas forcément eu s'il était
dans les mêmes conditions que qui s'il
aurait pas forcément eu de résultats
flamboyants sens sans être complètement
ridicule non plus parce qu'il n'est pas
ridicule au candidat loin de là il n'a
perdu qu'une partie ans
en cinq matches c'est pas non plus la
cata mais c'est un peu léger pour jouer
en ligue 1 manque un peu d'expérience un
peut-être après moi j'ai vu son père
récemment il a pour apprendre pas là
forcément pour gagner les candidats
directement
après évidemment tout le monde
l'espérait enfin tout penser qu'il peut
faire quelque chose d'incroyable
mais lui il veut être champion du monde
mais il sait que tu peux pas brûler les
étapes
carlsen avait beaucoup de réussite en
2013 on les
fait un super tournoi puis tu es plus
âgé de 23 ans
et 90 des ventes de 22 23 ans
il fait déjà une différence est bon
à l'huile à 19 ans et c'est assez un
premier un truc en premier première
expérience pense que le deuxième sera
quand même pas il faudra se qualifier
parce que les filles et bien sûr c'est
pas fait un
attention tu vois moi quand je vois
firoud déjà joué comme ça après tout le
monde sait que j'ai un petit tu envie de
voir maxime bien joué je peux rien y
faire voilà et c'est comme ça il ya un
affect qui est malgré tout différent
même si rouge on adore le joueur on
adore le jeu avec maxime l'affect
l'affecté complètement différent et j'ai
envie de dire
attention quand même aux joueurs de la
génération de maximin parce que
mbl wesley so
we la niaiserie tu vois ça peut
ça peut largement rivaliser avec ce que
je vois ici donc ce sera pas dans la
poche puis bon il y aura de nouveau
l'écart ouanna il est digne irène faut
se les farcir un
heleven les bonnes aussi à devan mois
pour l' approche pour le prochain ainsi
que je le sent un peu moins
je ne réussis pas à le voir se
rester à ce niveau là
et puis il y aura aussi tous les ja on a
parlé de hand slimane un peu plus tôt
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faudra dans un an
il semble un peu léger mais bon il y
aura et ria ici peut-être prague ananda
et il a fait de gros résultats sur
internet qu'est ce qui vous rend l'ong a
fallu
ouais c'est là je sais mais attention
même
nom mais mais mais régate si c'est quand
même joue bien mais j'ai quand même pu
légère c'est léger je suis d'accord
c'est justement je pense que firoud
compte tous ces joueurs là il est
intraitable 1 par rapport aux autres
je pense aussi mais regardons ici piano
par exemple qui a été un moment donné 27
30 27 40 qui bat karl scène on se dit
tiens il arrive ça être le prochain un
peu russe qui va rentrer dans le top 10
et finalement il a perdu quoi il perd 50
points l'eau en un an saphir ou djahi
les
gpm peu j'aime pas le fait de le dire là
comme ça on a l'impression qu'on est en
train de juger son tournoi qui en fait
est pas mauvais mais toi t'es pas la
brique passé de 28 10 à 27,60 même en
étant jeunes d'avoir un joueur
d'envergure et sion quoi
donc à vrai dire
bon mais j'avais lui dire attention à
maxime tu vois je suis parti dans un
délire sur début je me suis dit faites
gaffe les gars est ce que ali reza sera
plus favori que maxime pour se qualifier
au prochain plan d'action
très bonnes chances de postes
requalifier un gamin j'en suis convaincu
j'en suis absolument convaincu quand tu
vois ce qu'il est en train de faire en
ce moment vraiment oui enfin malgré ce
coup de un peu de bon bout qu'il a pris
les comme fait de ton extraordinaire
ouais puis
quand il voit le candidat tu as
j'imagine un maxime par exemple tu vois
les candidats actuellement à ce terrible
tu dis quand même il se dit qu'il va
s'en faut c'est lassant fois c'est ça le
truc c'est ça que j'allais dire c'est
tuer des candidats ou les mecs sont
extraordinaires tu dis bon j'y suis pas
mais ok tu vois il ya quand même une
différence j'aurais jouer le milieu de
tableau quand tu vois ça tu dit maxime
alors on sais pas peut-être qu'il serait
8e actuellement comme comme ali reza ou
peut-être qu'ils seraient provient
danser rien mais tu ne dis pas il aurait
pas pu tu vois ce que je veux dire il
aurait eu il aurait eu sa chance autant
que fabiano tant que néo peau tant que
hikaru hikaru qui jusque-là barefoot
très bien
il aurait eu sa place lewes les pareil
si regarde sur ce que vous êtes les
seuls à quand ils voient ce qu'ils
voient et se dit
alors être bio
des extraits déjà plus trois mois après
c'est dur on s'est pas fait c'est ce sas
jouad sur tellement de choses
attention à karpov prochain candidat
n'est pas tournoi aussi il veut faire un
remake de l'année dernière
jusqu'à hier voix il a très bien joué
mais pas du couffo epsilon
[Musique]
d'alger 4 mai pour voir fou
17,4
tu veux essayer de dans un cahier c3f 4
5 km
c'est
à lui veut ça et ça mais bon
c'est tellement dur à voir je trouve ces
coûts toi tu les vois facilement partis
les coups comme souffrances et 3 pour
moi c'est vraiment assez pour
enregistrement d'une destruction de
structures satin polar
et faire jouer ton foot et pions sur les
casinos opposé à t'en fous tu joues et 6
e 5 fois aussi c'était mieux
pour moi c'est extrêmement dur je le
comprends quand je le vois mais c'est
extrêmement dur
on ne peut pas jouer qu'à et c3 donc
d'alger cas j'ai bien aimé le coup de 7
les deux n'en ferais attention et à 3
g side pour sortir du clivage rien
weill est sorti c'est dead
et dam des trois c'est pareil dam des
trois fous
17,4 km et
ouais alors dame eux deux en fait ouais
dames 2 peut arriver dans les deux cas
sûr mais la dame angers 4 ont des 3
5 et moins bons écoutants ferme-t-on fou
c'est assez ça pour un
massage ou la rb6 mal placé la case des
cinq énormes forcément c'est un fou au
5-1 au sein clients embêtant
mais pour pas laissé jouer sur la case
des 5,5
sary ce que de s'aplanir rapidement fait
fabiano qui est quand même assez
impressionnant encore aujourd'hui un peu
ce que dame détroit c'était à mon avis
très venimeux et il en est sorti genre
elle a bien liquider le truc
quasiment instantanément
et tu vois c'est là aussi quand tu
parlais différence par rapport à des
joueurs de ce calibre là on dam des
trois contre un mec à 26 81 27 peut-être
que tu réussis vraiment à faire mal
hélas le sait le niveau pas que ces
niveaux au dessus c'est que ces niveaux
juste le plus haut possible caruana
difficilement faire mieux à part carl
scène et c'est extrêmement précis
jeter un petit coup d'oeil aux autres
parties complètement
on va commencer justement par
par ian contre jean-christophe
et ça s'en aller un peu mieux c'est
clair la russie a placé une petite idée
en ouverture et on a cette majorité face
au roc qui va arriver ce cinq contre
trois quand même en fait si on regarde
bien c'est pas facile quand tu rock de
se prendre de se prendre ça
ça risque d'arriver
fort et encore une heure 47 pour pour
yann contre une heure 1h09 attention à
yann il est déjà plus de six langues
aille encore unissant voit l'un
est très bonne ouverture des blancs il
bénéficie encore de sa préparation à la
à mener il a joué une petite ouverture
voilà où paye pas de mine mais il a
amené son exercice exactement là où il
voulait pas qu'ils étaient d'ailleurs
avec maxime automne
il avait joué le cavaliere 3 dans la
partie décisive des candidats précédents
contre maxime prêts au premier coup
dans cohen dépôts qui a une bonne
position
radjabov il semblait dans une position
qui pouvait devenir compliqué entre
rapporte laurent blanc tu dors là c'est
là
mon pronostic c'est que ça va être une
après midi très compliqué pour radjabov
et rapporte s'il gagne lui aussi un peu
commencé
à se placer
aia est difficile parce que la position
est très tactique et très tactique 1 les
finales vont être dangereuse
[Musique]
a tant fait à paris johnny finale parce
que le roi on 17,6 sera plutôt en
sécurité mais au final voilà les noirs
ils ont peut-être joué flou 17
ils vont peut-être prendre en f3 aussi
un jour aussi
matériellement c'est quoi ils m'aiment
pas de plus en plus pour les blancs a
énoncé hyper chaud pression dernier coup
j'ai cinq à jouer et à regarder c'est ce
qu'on avait fauché cinq tours et fuite
pas de dames point f3
de vouloir se garder en fait tu est un
hacker g4 qui rôdent noël kg quête
attention et s'y prend il va vouloir
reprendre d'un pion au centre et faire
le gros centre
on verra hélas et la dernière partie
c'est pas née pose c'est celle de naka
contredit gnaka un haka qui semblait
avec les blancs en légère difficulté
ça c'est ça c'est comment ça c'est ça
c'est ça des rita et noir ont réussi à
faire ces 5
il n'a pas pris du cheval
as tu prends du cheval et écoute
installe un gros truc en d4 en faute
donc il a préféré prendre du fou
ouais mais pas si mal s'ils arrivent à
faire cette poussée ces cinq à décaler
la dame et ses 5
ya pas trop de problèmes en sont rois le
fou 17 contrôler toutes les cases
important de cavaliers f5 impossible
d'alger cat impossible et b5 un possible
soutien tout
enak acquis encore 1h53 alary doat en
semi-bluff en tout jouer tempo ça peut
pas être une prépa ça c'est impossible
incroyable non 503 c'est incroyable
j'ajoute ou tempo il se prend pas la
tête hikaru et donc ali reza qui a joué
le dame g4 mais non ça va pas il va rien
y avoir
seb
tu fais tu peux pas attaquer avec une
seule pièce
alors là il ya que la dame qui est
développée
c'est pas grand chose un g4 fou 17
ans que je te propose qu'on fait
habituellement on est à une heure 1h07
de jeu on se fait on sait ce qu'on
appelle le résumé express on a en une
minute ok pour pour revoir la partie
depuis le début
donc je te lance la balle allait marche
donc c'était la partie numéro c'est la
partie numéro 6 ali riza firoud jaa
contre yann contre yannick c'est la
partie numéro 6 alireza chirugien contre
fabiano caruana et ali riza qu'il ya
ouvert par des quatre scènes ouais leur
part des cas donc petite surprise mais
ils pouvaient le jouer comme un os 4 est
donc là on a eu une ouverture catalan
donc caractérisé par le coucher trois
pour mettre le front fuyant kétou donc
là c'était voilà c'est la vraie surprise
du joueur ce que firent ouldja n'est pas
habitué à jouer c'est ouverture donc fou
j'ai deux foulées sept cavaliers f3 rock
est ici la deuxième énorme surprise avec
très peu de parties dans la base d'amd
3o la dame détroit qui sait la marque de
vladimir kramnik derrière ce coup il n'y
a pas de doute et il a essayé de sortir
très rapidement caruana de sa prépa ce
qui est plutôt comme une bonne idée
mais pendant pendant le direct et virait
qu'il faut un peu provoqué des princes
et 4 mai fabiano qui va bien réagir par
assez sage et très bien en essayant de
jouer contre le mauvais positionnement
de la dame en d3 donc allez prends des 4
ric6 et prend des 5 et prend des quatre
dames prend des quatre cavaliers prend
des cinq tours d un
fouet si ces dames g4 donc on en est là
seb à la sortie de l'ouverture et il
semblerait que fabiano soit sorti du
plus dur ouais je pense qu'il va jouer
fou 17la hilare a fini son développement
les blancs comme du coup un retard de
développement avec seulement
va-t-elle dame qui a encore au
chaud avec le camion bien il faut en
série à tour en un donc je vois bien les
noirs égaliser tranquillement et fou 17
pouces et 6 et attention ce que parfois
ça peut vite se retourner contre les
blancs ses positions on verra seb on n'a
plus qu'à on a plus qu'à attendre je
vais écrire à ludwig pour qu'il puisse
nous faire le petit point c'était le
petit point à l'heure de jeu
qui est réussi
mais voit une ouverture un petit peu on
à andy gray c grésy beaucoup disent
qu'on ordi maintenant mon micro ton
micro grésy
qui disent à deux personnes deux
personnes
un poil
non pas du tout ça va
il touchera joue je pense à ses tapas
qui touche et ajouts à oui toi je me
suis rasé ce matin oui mais c'est
peut-être parce qu'ils touchent étage où
elle je décale
s'était pas grésillés du coup c'était
grise il n'était pas le mot ça sera un
autre bruit où s affrontent ouais
ouais ouais ça frotte ça frotte a gelé
des cahiers
ouais c'est ça c'est pas grésillés c'est
un autre c'est un autre mot
cdu frotti frotta ouais c'est différent
c'est du frottement frau todd hays
frotta trop ted
white space et lycées il a dû se décaler
petit à petit
j'ai quatre dames g4 jouer et alireza on
va le revoir à la cam
et parents qui faute
il doit en avoir marre de ce tournoi à
la déposition qu'il a plutôt
après ils adorent josé chacun
pense pas qu'il en ait marre et ben
parle quand il en a marre quand les
positions sont sont pas dans son
cas ce qu'il cherche
et oui tu peux pas imposer à ce niveau
là ton style de position c'est plus
possible
à partir de quel niveau ça devient
difficile de
[Musique]
de pouvoir jouer un peu forcé ses
positions genre pour toi c'est déjà plus
possible j'imagine tu peut plus forcer
les cases noires aller non je veux
quand tu commences à jouer les joueurs
au dessus de 2006 il fait faut il faut
il faut être fois que c'était tous les
styles de jeu tu peux pas
alors je dirais quand même la différence
se fait à 2007 et 2007
la moindre erreur ils vont pas de punir
mais il termine là où ils veulent
des messages tout est bon fou 17 joué
comme prévu
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé entre la
ronde entre les trois premières rondes
ou alireza semblait dominer les
ouvertures les mêmes les quatre
premières et l'art entre 5 et 6 et
difficile à savoir est ce que ses
adversaires ont pu percer un secret
arrête ton contre caruana donc là c'est
compliqué hein caronna c'est le meilleur
pour les ouvertures
au quai hier hier c'était contre duda
cd en bon théoriquement mais je pense
pas qu'ils aient la même force de frappe
que
vivant il était très près ce qu'est ce
qui est étonnant c'est que ce qu'il a
joués c'était le truc le plus prêt fin
c'est peut-être pas mais c'était dans
l'est dans le très prévisible
il a rencontré une petite espagnole à
journée de repos
ça ça peut coûter cher
à cet âge là après t'as plus
l'expérience complexe
tu as aussi beaucoup de joueurs on en
parlait on en parlait hier pendant live
et a beaucoup jours à cet âge là qui
commence va découvrir les plaisirs de la
vie
on rigole mais c'est vrai et qu'il peut
y avoir une phase de régression lié à ça
on en parle et quand on parlait des cip
ian cosco et en plus il un peu beau
gosse malgré tout
aller non mais c'est sûr
si penco band forest
et ouais ça peut mais je crois qu'il est
dans l'est dans les clubs de foot
il y avait un entraîneur alors je me
rappelle plus le nom
mais il voulait que tous ces joueurs de
l'équipe i d'un c'est une équipe de
premier league ou vendre une énorme
équipe se marient avant les 21 ans
histoire de fille à problèmes et c'est
vrai que dans son équipe le taux était
très très élevée du coup les joueurs
étaient beaucoup plus présents à
l'entraînement dans les matchs moins
fatigués mais non mais c'est allé guy
roux à auxerre l'heure guy roux s'était
pas à ce point là mais c'est vrai qu'ils
vont vite et il était là le guillou ce
nom mais clairement c'est singer ça fait
partie de la vie et c'est des choses qui
forcément ou un impact très très très
directs sur ton jeu quand tu es sportif
ça c'est évident donc et à cet âge là
voilà enfin j'ai pas si on est tous
adultes la dent du chat tout ici mais je
gère tous les gens qui ont dépassé les
20 la vingtaine
25 25 ans on va dire savent très bien de
quoi on parle
et ça peut ça peut avoir un impact
direct et saïfi roule déjà il est dans
ce vraiment dans cette tranche d'âge
valait pas la peine
mais le problème ne serait peut-être pas
cramique finalement
ils magnus il a eu ce problème et ce
problème on
[Musique]
line side comme quoi il ya un tournoi où
ce n'est pas un match de championnat du
monde où il ya eu pas passé comme prévu
avec sa copine
séparation et ça a été très compliqué
sur son niveau de jeu ouais mais c'est
assez normal donc ça arrive enfin
absolument tout le monde est dans
absolument tous les sports tous les
sports
qui pour fêter mes 20 ans le 21 octobre
devant maxime celui-là max
et non mais c'est ali reza ça c'est un
pur c'est saint pons de l'avis des
joueurs ou quoi que tu que tu peux pas
savoir quand tu regardes comme ça il
peut se passe enfin il ya tellement de
facteurs comme ça qu'ils jouent
sur lesquels tu parles et puis dinger la
digue
l'info n'a aucune info
on sait même pas si les maris en fait
cet
avis ce sens la maison sérieuse mariage
assez jeune et peut-être déjà des
enfants
logique
cherche un poste
chez un pote qui qui qui avec qui avec
une fille chinoise il se trouve que tu
as un bon on a tous des pâtes quoi et il
m'a dit ouais c'était un peu en mode
enfant à 24 25 ans quand
les digues l'on sait même pas si l' on
sait rien en fait en vrai
on pourrait vous dire
qu'il a une copine sérieuse à une époque
là qu'il est célibataire elle m'envoie
on sait pas vraiment ce pas tout le
temps il a quatre gosses et j'ai envoyé
valser la lys et de faire du rock
un peu oui oui alors là ça rend un pote
ding dong l'argent du prize money à sa
mère selon de chasse base india
en tout cas on peut pas savoir
mais tout ça pour dire que ça peut avoir
un impact réel et très très directe sur
le niveau de jeu
cali reza est peut-être en zone de
turbulences
qu en est-il de même veine mais plus tu
te laisses je suis posé la question un
joueur d'échecs à simon probablement un
sex-appeal 2 0 et sont pas blancs a
sectionné pièces qu'on lit
c'est terrible tu as presque tout faux
kulti
complexe van der geer il est marié
depuis longtemps qu'on nous parle des
joueurs de haut niveau
magnus on le voit assez souvent stream
avec
des amis différente on va dire ça comme
ça
les bonnes malheureusement lui c'était
plus compliqué sa femme
ak je crois qu'il y ait une copine
depuis quelques temps il était qu'une
italienne dans un allemand alors
maintenant je suis moi qui s'est séparé
de l'italienne mais bon une
caruana aussi dont il a dit y'a pas
longtemps choix que j'ai lu qu'il y
avait une copine car rien qu'au piano
donc ouais radjabov il est divorcé je
crois qu'il est hors mariage s'est
remarié way
dans les combien qui ajoute à douzat
l'on sait rien wen au delà je pensais
pas grand chose est très jeune aux
25es rapporté par tout le temps de sa
copine ah oui ça fait très longtemps
qu'ils sont éric ouais il y aurait 7
contre maxime malheureusement la prépa
c'était la prépa de la femme de rapport
qui doit faire très très faim praxyval
heureusement tu as ta balle perdue
trouver une copine qui envoient des
prépas
carats vous avez closer elle est bon
très bon très bon magazine
pourquoi ils sont quasiment tous nous
ont tous été en couple il ya peu en
réalité là on a presque revue tous les
tous les candidats et nous manques qui
n'a qu'à on a dit radjabov rapporte
qu'un polar couple né doit en couple
avec snejana ouais
ils sont quasi tous en couple en vrai
on la voit jamais sur les photos signées
jana elle est toujours là un poil était
là en sibérie
sympa ou pas alors 7 mai jana
elle vous parle pas du pain est pas
beaucoup de sourires qui partent du
visage comme
aller assez fermé ouais c'est fermé
mais je crois que j'ai dû voir un
sourire le jour voilà ici qualifier
ça va pas plus loin
il ya un bon petit plat et un bon
morceau de viande n'ont pas de sou
mais il est tout le temps avec owen oui
mon il mangeait très souvent semble
peut-être bleu midi je crois pas mais le
soir ils vont le sourire ensemble
important
mais ça c'est vrai ça peut ça peut
réellement influer de manière importante
sur le niveau de jeu
est là ali reza il manque peut être ni
signé jane a en fait un
plus un joli prénom ce que signale qu'en
russe ça veut dire neige
snejana c'est un peu ça fait un peu flou
conquois
question pensent tout bas lors de cette
ouverture
la u2 fab l'oeil du coach
donne des trois ne
pas parler dans le micro c'est une
viande ce truc fab
non je sais pas trop quoi dire doivent
d'être où je connaissais pas
et ce que je vois maintenant
régal quoi ça très excitant
même tour mais tu peut mal tourner un
emploi ligne 4 qui avait six qui a
essayé trois fous ces trois puis on
prend ces 3,5
épiquement le genre de truc qui tourne
très très mal
ouais faut c'est de céder là nul ne peut
être que nous prendre trop de risques
j'ai pas vu enfin à judas menés 3 buts
et joué que ces 5 et puis après ils ont
tout est changé en d4 c4
sait pas trop quelle était l'idée de
détroit du coup
on se passe là prépare pour le match de
demain j'ai pas commencer à faire des
petits matches 2 buts ce soir
et là je vais faire un petit tour et
puis tu auras plage dans la ville et
tout c'est vous les cheveux c'est
au petit monoprix
non au grand monoprix je vais t'envoyer
l'adresse un précieux petit effet ouais
bien sûr a donc failli rentrer dans vos
doigts d'or
demain qui joue à 19h30 un match
d'exhibition contre krikor
non mais il est hyper d'enfin je sais
qu'ils ont c'est parfois la mémoire
jouer le 4
way est au dessus
le manu ferrera brésilien
ressemble vraiment qu'un je le
rappellerai toujours de sa tête quand il
a tapé manu ferrera et images dans
google je rappellerai toujours de
s'adapter sur le las il était là tout
chantant
ailleurs my french menu ferrat était
très heureux with it et toulouse je
rappelle qu'il a regardé
ouais ok
rien
tu venais la bouteille de
vourles avant pour pas qu'elle explose
ici
chef qui est des arcs enfermé avec celle
c'est vrai on a pu boucler la
pourquoi ces mauvais faut prendre et
cinq mâts le truc c'est comme le disent
et sablé carte blanche c'est important
et on peut passer avec la clé là cette
position c'est arrivé alors le fou en d4
lower
si tu arrives à mettre le fou en d4 ici
tu es mieux avec les blancs parce que du
coup tu as un pion isolé
donc là on a l'exemple ou si on peut
bloquer sur des quatre y installer un
cavalier en aura une bonne position
malheureusement là dès qu'on va bouger
la dame les noirs ont joué des 4 par
exemple
d'un f3 des 4 hélas le fou venir
s'installer en c6 et le carnage
sur la diagonale
donc voilà ça c'est très dangereux à
éviter même sûrement jeu le pion
bessette
il ya des gros problèmes un par exemple
on peut montrer dame premier set
simplement tour ses huit avec le fou qui
vient en c6 le prochain coup
suivi de la dame qui va venir en d5 et
ensuite c'est le mama c'est le mama
c'est le mama tu
donc ça c'est clairement à éviter voilà
donc vous prend des cinq pas possible
et le problème c'est que b3 b3 en perles
la tour
et si on joue à quatre
pour chasser ce cavalier on enferme
notre fou quand même
enferme notre fou j'ai deux je sais pas
problème pour
pour les réserves
lors dispositions légales mais
seule chance pour les blancs ceux de jeu
4 et dames de la et son nez on est on
est sur
place et eu quatre cavaliers b6 et dames
eu deux
attaques bourne
dames 2 est bon
c'est cette part est quand même
pour se développer les blancs veulent
peut-être essayer de faire au 5ème set
pour empêcher
ces lignes qu'on a vu tout à l'heure au
f4 fou aux 5
et ça c'est complètement égal
malheureusement et ses trois tours des 8
f cap dame bouge il ya pas grand chose
dit ces deux lignes dont on parlait tout
à l'heure
peut-être la meilleure chance peut-être
quelque chose comme ça en juin 1,5 et
après
c'est un peu insipide un insipide mais
bon je peux peut-être il peut essayer de
jouer on va pas se mentir mais on est
quasiment sûr de 4 forcella à kayes et
des deux que c'est un coup qu'est d2
key2key quatre cols
une petite daisy des sacs ou encore
wayne disons dames 7 qui paraît être un
coup logique car quatre
ans ça c'est une option
je pars envoyée
il ya les vraiment en force quoi
on y va un peu trop fort cette
info f4 f5
d'alger 5 et tout reprendre et 5
et même ça l'a aidé à me prendre à mes
tours prend sept enfants 17
meilleur
hockey on a deux coups intéressants
peut-être qui a aidé deux ou quatre
cahiers des deux gemmes plus développe
développer ces pièces 4 comme ces
quatre c'est ça commence à faire trop de
huawei provoquer un peu
vais les frais qui des deux a ici
probablement
car ils ces trois ceintures boudreau qui
inciteront on a vu que ça n'allait pas
trop un prêt ou quatre encaissés 3
europe
message important
enfin autour des stades là si je l'aï
vas-y vas-y
tu veux faire un petit tour ouais c'est
aux deux endroits c'est les mêmes alors
attends je fais juste je te fais juste
un
tac vas-y vas-y ok donc là on a
cette position là
j'allais chercher le pion des quatre
temps s'était arrêté ou sur touré fuite
pourrait fuite
ces trois jouées par radjabov bien jouer
pour ouvrir la position roi au centre un
site numéro un
fou des six puis on prend des cats dame
prend des quatre
donc là il ya deux belles colonnes une
pour les noirs avec la colonne f et une
pour les blancs que la colonne d
attention
attention radjabov il va falloir trouver
l'unique ou qu'ils perdent pas ici
radjabov est déjà dans le dur hein
ouais sous la menace ses cavaliers j'ai
kg 4 avec une énorme
énorme attaque sur f2
radjabov coups critiques coups critiques
pour radjabov il faut trouver
retrouvé une défense et c'est pas facile
dans me2 par exemple si on bouge la dame
on verrait très bien que c'est la
catastrophe kg 4 f3 et a5 avec le fou
qui coulisse
qui serait synonyme
d'exécution pour les blancs
radjabov en gros danger obligé de jouer
le seul coup
eux
qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autres ont nakamura
ding donc nakamura qui est en mode
express
une heure d'avancé à la pendule
et position peut-être position
supérieure pour nakamura
un peu plus agréables peut-être c'était
peut-être prépa en fait c'est parce
qu'on n'a rien compris c'est tout
envoyer le tempo
est ce que tu as envie qu'ils gagnent à
4 quand même c'était un joueur on a
envie qui gagne qui perd non c'est pas
en fait frais à j'ai envie qu'ils
fassent un bon tournoi ils viennent les
candidats je pense
troisième ouais même 2,6 après en finale
et c'est vrai je pense pas les frais et
d'annoter et voir un carlson naka finale
championnat du monde même pas sûr que
nakheel le jouera deux matches risque
trop
trop dur pour lui donc radjabov rapporte
tension rajhi avec un coût pour s'en
sortir est née peau
envoie la sauce est très très belle
position très très belle position là
c'est vraiment une belle position c'est
très très très dangereux avec les noirs
quel sens il va arriver
challenger optimale pour toi maso vlad
nous a dit que pour lui c'était caruana
ou 10 meding
maintenant ça semble plus dur mais pour
toi rats et garonne la roma aussi
d'un quart one east
ouais après je pense aussi sulky de
challenge le plus magnus il pose
vraiment beaucoup de problèmes
c'est ce que tu dises un peu laurent
frayssinet que et les idées partout il
fait que travailler il tient bien la
pression il craque pas il est bien
physiquement en soit il a tout quoi ya
pas de défaut ouais ce serait un peu le
chaque jour tu sais que il va essayer de
chercher quelque chose pour gagner ouais
c'est un peu le challenger c'est un peu
les deux meilleurs joueurs en fait de la
décennie ouais on y réfléchit c'est
celui qui a été le plus longtemps
installé à la seconde place au
classement mondial
et pour dépôt c'est plus dur
n'est pas avec la cartouche qui l'a
prise c'est très très dur mais bon après
je pense qu'en fait que physiquement
justice pourra pas indéfiniment c'est
trop dur quand appris tellement cher
et firoud qui réfléchit et exactement
comme tous les autres jours il en train
de rattraper son adversaire à la pendule
sais c'est pas c'est pas le même fia où
on a perdu on n'a pas le bon n'a pas le
bon fiorucci
peut-être il va falloir qu'il prenne
comme maxime sur les tournois en fait
tout cas il jouait du championnat
d'europe quoi qu'il en soit ce que m'a
dit son papa ils t'ont proposé est ce qu
est ce qu on rentre dans un secret si on
me demande ça déjà non mais bon après
c'est vrai qu'on s'entend très bien est
ce que tu as été approché ou pas pour ça
a été mentionné à man mais bon après il
rit le tome 2 top 16 et c'est donc un
mais il ya eu l'oeil a pas eu de trucs
officiel mais après c'est moi c'est
vraiment très très bien et que les
raisins ça discutait quoi quand même
avec maxime
si c'est possible de l'aider c'est avec
plaisir as-tu nous lâche quand même une
info non mais j'ai pas une info je te
sens je suis pas un second temps mais
après c'est vrai qu'on a eu voilà sont
je pense que son père à apprécier
comment ça s'est passé en survie donc
pourquoi pas dans le futur qui s'est
battu mais un peu quand même l'ambiant
moi je suis là pour l'ambiance ça
et non mais ça et tu mets un peu la
bonne humeur le matin
non mais c'est important quand même
ouais mais bon c'est clair non mais
après c'est une question de feeling
ça peut ça peut faire la différence en
avoir
annoncé dans ces tournois il faut que
tout se
passe bien quoi fin que
la wii est entouré dans tous les
compartiments
avoir fait sien mvl et firoud déjà
belle c'est mon chouchou on va tu peux
être avec les deux là un premier dîner à
19 heures avec
après je rêve elle à 23 heures
c'est ça adil mazet ça
il ya le chien qui vient nous voir comme
toujours vers 16h30 on a une petite
habitude maintenant ça vient de dire
bonjour ça va voir les parties place
avec aujourd'hui en plus en plus on
n'est pas gâté ça n'avance pas très vite
passe pas grand chose la siesta
aujourd'hui
cadets 2 1
score qu'à et des deux clubs on ne
pensait que ce serait notre rayon de
soleil scène dans ses candidats
mais peut-être tu seras pour un live
alors je vous renvoie en parler
maintenant rapidement mais il va
peut-être y avoir un live d'anthologie
j'ai envie de dire
dimanche soit le matin soit le soir
puisque si c'est possible on va essayer
de retransmettre ton premier tour en
direct
ça ce serait exceptionnel en fait on
n'est pas venu suivre les candidats on
va on va se rattraper
ouais c'est possible que mon premier
tour soit dimanche
samedi
et dimanche à jour est de reposer ça
demain c'est vrai que je joue le matin
demain ou mardi donc en fait si tu
passes
je passe beaucoup de temps à deux tours
non
un petit live font prendre un 0 0
vous avez mentionné les stratèges
français c'est vrai qu'une équipe de
seconde en français pourrait faire mal
un message on a d'excellents théoriciens
en france et genre d'école de seconde en
quoi au final
et frais signer par exemple son histoire
avec ne sait pas que les échecs c'est
quelqu'un qui est proche quand même
inquiet pour le mec est très agréable à
voir dans son équipe
mais ça devenait un peu la mentalité à
la française c'est à dire
un travail et alors ça travaille
énormément
stratosphérique et c'est aussi une main
qui est très agréable à vivre
on est français quoi ré français voilà
ça mange bien ça fait du sport ça rigole
bien
et pas que
ça près ce que l'autre ce qu'on fait ici
on sait tous pourquoi vlad et
francophiles oui
mais ça on n'a pas cité vlad tout à
l'heure dans les français qui sont des
des théoriciens de renoncer à la cité
on a dit pas qui on est bien on a pas de
livrade d'origine russe mais quand même
c'est en fait encore en plus qui l'a de
sept patrons
banquiers vannes ils sont un peu dans le
même
même école on va dire baky qu'on verra
normalement dimanche
qui m'a écrit ce matin il voulait passer
aujourd'hui pour te voir mais je lui dis
que tu restais pour le tennis pour le
super atik jusqu'à mercredi
et si tu passes plus de tours
après
je pense je vais quand même rentré en
jeu ouais même si tu as appris mercredi
c'est comme si je vais être sur des pros
là
je change de carrière si je suis là
mercredi recommandant
même cité cavare gros ça veut dire que
j'ai je bats des joueurs qui sont
négatifs
ok foutu bat un mec qui soit genre ce
que monsieur batta un grand maître aux
échecs
ouais au moins ma travailler le truc
c'est qu'au tennis tu sais pas c'est pas
un point ni un jeu ou un set c'est un
match qu'on a c'est incroyable je pense
est plus facile de battre un grand
maître aux échecs sur une partie que bat
un joueur au tennis beaucoup plus fort
que toi est ce que tu faisais chacune
partie là tu l'as tu joues à
l'équivalent d'une dizaine de partis way
de trois blessures ça va vite après
opéra blessure à caen bon si on parle de
joueurs en forme
on n'a pas cité dorfman dans l'eau des
théoriciens français on aurait dû on a
réduit ouais
c'est lui qui a sûrement amené cette
cette touche oui il a eu et tiennent ils
à lui mathieu il aura il leur a montré
comment on peut travailler violemment d
ouverture
baky à baky c'est vrai que c'est aussi
un gros morceau d'ouverture très très
réputé
on a l'habitude de mute aussi demuth qui
est qui deux travailleurs de l'ombre en
équipe de france j'ai déjà fait trois
fois je crois car en slovénie s'était
lui
il reste à la maison mais il est de tous
les joueurs
et il travaille très très bien
spécialiste de cavalière 3 c'est ça et
j'ai 3 way très peu de choses écrit des
très bons vivants
est là et ce qu'on sait si roux déjà
mises à part chez paris n'a fait qu rami
qui a pas d'information qui ont filtré 1
y'a pas l'infirmer on sait pas parce que
forcément l'équipe ne s'arrête pas akram
[ __ ] franchement s'il doit y avoir des
joueurs qui sont
qui sont peut-être choisi par crown et
qui est celle par une offre pour
travailler des lignes que eux mêmes
choisi ce oui c'est un peu un peu comme
ça marche avec nilsen puis freyssinet
qui eux-mêmes choisissent d'autres
joueurs qui délègue oui donc la liste
très nombreux
on diffuse passé second dans ça
donnerait des informations à tout
simplement on voit par exemple avec
carlson on sait qu'il travaille avec du
boeuf est très souvent cela nous fait
souvent remarquer d'ailleurs pas son du
double of derrière dans des choses que
je joue 40 cents à ce manque de bol
souvent de forêt ce qu'ils ont joué
avant même sur des beats sur internet ou
des bottes de double of des bottes de
vente fort est assez sûr pour un peu
testé
surtout que maintenant pour tester sur
internet c'est devenu dur puisque les
partis sont maintenant publiés 1 il faut
les faucons riffaud les comptes cachés
quoi bref quand même des coûts ne cacha
pas c'est que j'en joue 28 ils font
comme moi à force il joue plus on joue
un compte caché comme malheureusement à
partir d'un certain lots une fois sur
trois c'est un tricheur donc tu
commences à cliquer au hasard
donc pour avoir vraiment une répartie et
east était quand même obligé de passer
par ton vrai conte fini
est-ce que tu va tenter le global
championship sur czech comme on
entendrait parler alors de base
s'appelle awards online chez ce
championship qui a été renommé parce que
le titre de champion du monde ça a créé
un conflit avec la fidh mais c'est de
chasse comme qui organise donc un
événement un championnat du monde sur
internet a complètement avec je crois un
million de dollars de prize pool
et des tours de qualification je sais
pas où ils en sont parce qu'il ya tout
le monde peut jouer donc là tu as eu des
tours de pré qualif pour les moins de
1200 les moins de 1800 les moins ligne
voilà c'est un peu complexe mais à
partir d'un moment donné je peux pas te
dire quand je pense que c'est en août
ouais ce seront les joueurs de son
calibre qui commenceront à rentrer au
port
et avec avec des beaux prix même même
dans les qualifs ailleurs quoi je crois
que c'est ça suffit de top 164 monde tu
prend peut-être deux trois quatre mille
euros c'est pas le truc en tête jarrier
un beau un beau pactole et à la fin c et
k o qui gagne ça dépend si magnus joue
je pense que maxime par exemple le jour
à
ali reza aussi j'imagine oui faut pas
que ça soit pendant le
festival
est organisé enfin les font gaffe tout
ça ils font gaffe way
et la finale sera en physique pour les 8
tous les dix derniers joueurs je peux
pas dire exactement je me rappelle plus
j'ai lu mais je me rappelle plus
mais ça ce sera sympa
double partie des rares et me classer à
plus de 2700 lots ils sont moins de 40
oui oui non c'est sûr mais après il est
quand même en dessous du top top
en scène et comme il faut mentionner
rené dans les seconds en france est
reconnue l'avait été dans l'équipe de
karpov t'étais au courant de ça je
savais pas ouais
bon
faut-il être fort en maths pour jouer
aux échecs un bon niveau est ce que tu
es fort en maths voit saab ça va je
pense avoir une logique de nos cerveaux
ça aide est-ce que tu as eu le bac non
ça rassure
voilà g12 en physique qui aimeraient
coûter cher qu'est ce que tu as le
permis et ben voilà ouais ouais je suis
rassuré je suis très très bien je suis
en train de passer la highway avec ça à
la dinguerie dur ou pas chaud chaud
chaud code mais ça va ça a
entraîné un m'ont parlé de ça avec
etienne ya peu de joueurs d'échecs qui
ont le bac c'est vrai
freyssinet un pâle bas prix aux sdf un
truc c'est qu'on quant à 17 18 ans tu
joues beaucoup beaucoup
donc très compliqué après de revenir à
l'école et de fins de te concentrer
annoncé ça ça paraît étonnant parce que
les gens pensent ce genre d'échec mvl
c'est un peu le wes et l'extracteur les
extraterrestres c'est l'exception qui
rogers je pense pas qu'il ait le bac non
plus je ne le sens pas avoir le bac
et rogers je ne sais pas je pense pas
ça le package moi non plus un mais en
tic tac bakil aux jo on est carrément
faire un art qu'on s'est dit quand on
aura plus de temps
la quarantaine passée peut-être
concevoir un délire on essaiera de
passer le bac j'ai pensé aussi écoute tu
pourra nous rejoindre dans cette épopée
je pense que ça va être dur
ça peut être compliqué c'est plus facile
qu'avant
ouais mais pour des thèmes comme nous
as tu es confiant quand même restée
assez gros chance
toujours
taper 1 2 en physique et 1,3 à l'oral de
français
vla dahlback aussi et il faut dire que
quand il a passé en vain en russie c'est
pas facile face au havre on a
l'impression en france que dans d'autres
pays c'est très facile c'est pas plus
facile qu ici ou plus dur
il n'a toujours pas joué les allemands
il reste c'est vrai qu'il va se fut que
59 minutes ou n'a joué que douze coups
non mais vraiment c'est ya un problème
dans son rapport à lire et travaille
énormément
pour pas forcément jouer des coups
extraordinaires en plus
puisque vous pensez qu'une réflexion
supérieure à 30 40 minutes peut devenir
mauvaise car on s'embrouille sur les
variantes aux pressions pour toi ouais
souvent on fait souvent après leur
intuition km
enfin souvent on peut on peut je suis
sûr clyde à penser au bout de 30
secondes à calais des 2 4
qui sont équivalents plus ou moins
probablement ouais
après aux 4 je le sent quand même c'est
bizarre 4 sa ferme ton four
après bon si on arrive à faire un 4 4 2
5 ont même truc
mais il ya ce retard de développement
qui est en béton
il ordonne cavaliers c3
particulier car ces trois breaks et c3
pas facile hein
qu'est france et trois options prend ces
trois dames bouge
puisqu'après fois ci c'est mauvais alors
fois ci c'est pas que c'est un vrai
peut-être fou prend b2 mais juste sa
menace rien en fait même si on fait
juste 3 h 8 par exemple
retour au bercail
tu dois revenir pour défendre ton pions
exactement raj il a perdu comme de
ferrières était complètement foutu en
essayant d'attaquer
c'est le fameux théorème du pion f qui
bouge et qui affaiblit le roi très très
dangereux
ouais les raisins vraiment enfin sur les
deux trois derniers coups il a déjà pris
presque une heure c'est trop dur sco
radjabov a vu le coût
de savoir si rajab a fait en train de
sombrer il n'a pas joué en fait
il la joue
et il trouve un quand même les coups et
trouvant quand il faut sauver
nepomniachi
je suis inquiet pour duda
et du coup il nous reste ce qui nous
reste
à 4 ding
complexe sa clique de partout
c'est vrai que c'est complexe
ça peut se retourner contre les blancs
simoneau exception d ce cavalier
bloqueurs un peu le cavalier que hikaru
avait eu contre contre ali reza
finalement entre les cases noires
compliqué partie où j'espère qu'il y
aura un vainqueur soit hikaru pour
vraiment
revenir sur la tête ou dingli rennes
pour se lancer dans le tournoi j'ai
l'impression que nul n'arrange personne
ici au final ouais c'est clair
oh là là là là
c'est fragile
mc5 ses premiers auxquels j'ai pensé je
vois que c'est confirmé par le petit
module juste pour aller taper le cul en
fait
j'arrive à jouer - taper le pion jouer
dame prend bessin et c5 très très bon
pour les prénoms
ouais alors on sait très bien que le
seul contre jeu des blancs sera égale 4
mai qui sera tellement affaiblie sans
ces fameux pions en f1 quand il bouge ça
peut être fort
ça peut aussi créer des problèmes
attention ça peut c'est une partie qui
peut trouver dans un coût d'un côté ou
de l'autre et à beaucoup de parties
peuvent tourner aujourd'hui
ouais ça pourrait être le bain de sang
qu'on attend on n'aura pas 4 nuls c'est
le tourmalet aujourd'hui malheureusement
le seul à avoir une la seule position
plate de la journée c'est celle du
français
il réussit alors à presque il réussit
aussi moins avoir de grosses positions
parce qu'il est craint les joueurs les
joueurs le craignent un petit peu leur
ai aussi ont vu un sur les premières
rampes ses faiblesses en finale qui
était quand même assez criantes est ce
que tu sais toi comment ils travaillent
les finales actuellement août à prades
toit par exemple bons joueurs de finale
tu donnerais quels conseils pour ont
progressé en finale tu t'enfermes
pendant un mois
un entraîneur soviétique et puis tu
manges toutes les finales seule solution
seule solution il a joué le cavalier des
deux parce que très franchement
je parle que d'un point de vue technique
ainsi on enlève le côté calcul des
finales je pense que tu les joues
beaucoup mieux que ferroudja ce qui est
complètement anormal ou à la vue de de
son niveau mais après il est encore
hyper jeunes un peu mais c'est sûr que
sur quelques c'est tellement important
de nos jours les finales parce que je
les ai vus ouais c'était le la finale
contre rapporte tu sens que ça va pas du
tout quoi c'est une fille un problème de
rythme en fait
je veux qu'ils étaient deux
la d2 j'aime bien coup
logique
va chercher du cavalier e 4 il est là il
s'affaiblit pas
les finales en fait ça te permet c'est
ce que j'explique à chaque fois dans les
stages
et mal tu va sauver la position donc
parti que tu perds tu vas faire nul
voire l'inversé de
inverser le schéma même gagné la partie
et les partis qui sont nuls tu les
gagnes et partitions gagnants et
finalistes et gagnantes battu les gagne
aussi donc ça te fait quand même
beaucoup de points positifs meilleur
exemple ce serait la finale contre
contre hikaru un excellent joueur de
finale l'aurait peut-être senti que le
tourcoing est fille de faisait nul et
aurait pu maintenir l'attention plus
longtemps bien sûr ce qui lui restait
quand même une heure au moment où le to
run en fuite il a joué en 13 14 minutes
même si ce n'était pas facile à
comprendre que c'était nul tu peux sur
un coup comme ça on le voit parfois un
prendre une heure d'émission anodin il
assure une décision si responsable il a
joué en à peine 13 minutes il n'a pas dû
sentir que ça pouvait être nul et ça
c'est vraiment vrai comme tu dis un
rien ressenti de par le travail quoi
et du coup est-ce que même un joueur
comme toi tu pourrais aider un fil rouge
a progressé en finale
après il faut après tu peux
oui après voilà c'était les instruments
et puis tu es les positions et tu fais
ça tu t'entraînes il suffit voilà
j'étais un bon grand maître qui dead ça
suffit un kit force à travailler
travailler enfin c'est juste un bosseur
et puis après
après les corridas comme quoi il a
côtoyé vachement de très fort joueur
donc ils arrivés là plein de thèmes
assez on a déjà parlé de ces trucs avec
avec maxime d'emblée finale de dames
voilà c'est une petite phrase que spirou
nous avait expliqué mais les dames en c4
c5 et f4 f5
meilleur endroit pour les dames au final
c'est plein de petites phrases comme ça
qui te font
et des kits avant sedan comme des six
points de repère quoi le petit point de
repère
être dans le carré comme je sais c'est
bien le faire
et donc ça a forcément en étant entouré
de joueurs comme cramique houphouet les
conseils peut les avoir mais bon on sent
que c'est un problème qu'il a qu'il a du
mal à régler
donc il a joué dams est
normalement il devrait y avoir qu'un
valeo 4 ici c'est ben voilà y'a 4
paraît logique donc il va sauver le fou
on avait cette position est là
et là on savait pas trop on avait
regardé fou j'ai cinq fois f4
et kg 5 du coût sun quoi qu'est
g5l genre sur un fils d'un me 4 quand
même peut-être ouais ça va pas f5 bras
logique
et bref 5 s'est affaiblie attention
et la tactique et ron
ensemble est peut-être que tu peux avoir
qui avait des points 6
on va espérer qu'ils aillent là dedans
en fait ali reza j'espère qu'il va jouer
vite surtout la cavalier des deux dames
set c'était quand même un des coûts
principaux et qui repartent pas dans ces
20 minutes mais gérard c'est
façon c'est là que tu sens si un joueur
est dans le rythme ou pas si sur le coup
qui paraît principal il remet encore 15
minutes c'est qu'il ya forcément un
problème
et sata une explication toi rationnelle
pour ce truc là non je sais pas
ça t'arrive an passé quelque chose qui
devra il devra travailler dessus parce
que c'est même mieux de jouer un coût
moyen mais avant de mettre une pression
autant que
que plombé comme ça enfin ça peut pas
être bon de plomber autant dans autant
de parties mais après cavaliers d2 on
est bien d'accord il a réfléchi
39 min pour qu'il y ait des deux c'est
pas possible qu'il ait pas regarder dams
est
donc il le sait forcément le coup qui va
jouer
c'est j'arrive pas à comprendre en fait
je n'arrive pas à m'expliquer à moi même
et à expliquer aux gens du coup au
passage à quoi il peut réfléchir en fait
pourquoi ce soc
c'est ça me dépasse en fait
ce que les autres joueurs le font pas ce
truc là
il a par un gris tchouk mais qui est un
fou furieux
fo demandé à guy ritchie ouais ce que
dit maxime regrette show qui va
enchaîner les coups comme oui il peut et
il va reprendre une heure un peu plus
tard la faire une petite série de trois
quatre coups et après avoir plongé
parce que ça c'est un coin tube tu as
passé 40 du circuit et des deux qui est
dame s'est tu va regarder à minima 15
minutes à minima
et surtout qu'il est capable de jouer un
cavalier e 4 30 15 on sortira le 4 il
fait fou et 5 et reprendre 20 minutes là
normalement en cinq minutes il a joué
cabrio 4
parce que
predator réfléchir calmement son actif
l'adap health and time travel junkie
mais il ya de ça un
nom mais là ya réellement enfin non mais
ça ça me rend fou ce que ça fait six
jours que je vois ça je sais que ça fait
possible y'a pas leur faire aujourd'hui
non c'est bon on lui a dit quand même
genre krasniqi lay lay
ce que la 28 coups wayne rooney
est sûre du moins de deux minutes par
cool que hills a fait aucun sens de
réfléchir là
j'ai vu les temps de réflexion ça fait
pas de sens et je vais pas comme ça au
champion d'europe non il jouait très
vite il clique et quan et cliquer
non mais moi c'est le truc si tu veux de
tous ces candidats c'est l'élément qui
me fait dire qu'il ya quelque chose qui
va pas gâcher pas qu'ils aient dans de
chatière que je suis un disque rayé que
je le répète tous les jours c'est vrai
mais parce que pour moi c'est tellement
un défaut criant qui est un problème
ça paraît
et à tout niveau j'ai l'impression qu'on
apprend ça aux amateurs déjà leur dire
bah voila si vous calculez longtemps un
coût et que l'autre je vous le couperet
ainsi par elsa il faut par galt culés
les lignes que vous n'êtes calculé avant
impôts vous jouez quoi
il est peut-être pas en confiance c'est
clairement ça il hésite à chaque coup
quoi
peut-être que là il repense à jouer aux
quatre enfants tu peut tout imaginer la
même
mais peut-être qu'il recoure commence à
calculer d'autres options
mais c'est sûr que ça va pas
et
c'est le seul à le faire ici en plus
t'as vu les fusées qu'on instaure la
pourrait dire y en a d'autres qui ont un
peu les mêmes tendances ou quoi mais ya
que lui qui fait ce truc qui est
vraiment
extrêmement
dérangeant j'ai envie de dire
il pensa fameux show des
adeptes de même chaud des joueurs de kay
saint-jules au pilotage
ouais ça te sert un peu ça ne s'érode tu
peux faire un truc pour te décès rothé
ouais tu peux le mettre sur le coup et
le tenir
jusqu'en tu tournes ta tête faut que tu
les infos que tu leur main correct qui
restent
les tempes sont pas bien l'impression
que
ouais non mais tu peux le tenir comme ça
si on si tu le tiens
rio de jules au pilotage
ouais mais non mais tu vois ça refait
cinq minutes encore faim c'est vrai de
paraître tous les jours je vais mais je
vais jouer et énervé comme hier comme
avant-hier comme tous les autres jours
mais ça me rend fou en fait
tu as l'impression qu'ils sabotent son
tournoi
en réalité c'est fou parce que là c'est
vraiment du sabotage
j'attends ton auto pour la sortir
j'atteins toronto pour la sortir je
pense qu'ils parlent de main de madame
chaude est ok les connaît pas du coup
il a connu deux par deux tirs
14 fan tu dis surtout que tous ses
adversaires le même remarque bien et
peuvent jouer là dessus ils doivent tous
halluciné en fait ils doivent rigoler le
soir ça vous fout à lire les a une
nouvelle fois
c'est sûr ça rigole dans son dos 1 ils
se foutent de sa gueule c'est sûr
la mairie doit repenser à eux quatre
sacs est fou
c'est exactement ce que kotov te dit pas
ferber
une fois que tu as calcul était variant
de côté sur
ouais il est trop nerveux alireza
attention quand même ne pas être une
étoile filante pour le joueur français
il ya quand même beaucoup de points à
travailler alors c'est rassurant parce
qu'on voit vraiment des zones de
progression clair dans son jeu ce qui
est d'un côté très rassurant vu le
niveau déjà
affiché cependant toujours la question
avec les jeunes joueurs esquisses ont la
possibilité de gommer leurs défauts que
jamais vraiment en être sûr 1
il faut savoir quand même qu'il va
arriver à son enfin son top dans 7 8 ans
10 ans quand même
ben oui mais bon
je pense qu'il va commettre est
d'ailleurs il a quand même pas mal comme
et récemment
alors là il va jouer
tu vas jouer aux cartes et le jeu
inquiète
il hésite encore une dernière fois le
coût est responsable à lui reste trois
quarts d'heure c'est le moment de clic
qui pense au fisc
non non mais tu vois voilà vraiment il
garde sa main sur sa tête j'ai pas
combien de temps et qui cavaliers f3
alors là mesdames et messieurs
il veut 4,5
pourquoi tour des huit ne va pas
f probablement un ce que tu joues au 4
juin au 5 mai ce que 4 je peux faire re
5 moi même
puisque le cavalier comme tu le disais
on doit taper la case des cinq quand ils
en c3 est extrêmement bien placé par
contre en f3 c'est pas terrible
donc en fait c'est même pas ça sont ni
je comprends même pas l'idée de
cavaliers f3 en fait
parce que si c'est fou j'ai 500 offres
absolument rien
annoncé c'est vraiment une partie sert à
rien attention d'ailleurs attention j'ai
envie d'y aller pour ces huit
vit dans le chat car il est froid j
avais même pas pensé bien nous non plus
on l'avait vraiment pas cavalier 3 ouais
non mais c'est clair j'ai choisi entre
eux qu'à tf3
surtout que même s'ils ont ils été fou
g5 en fait c'est mieux d'avoir dit
çà se marient tellement mal avec dame g4
en plus
c'est une ligne dorion en tout cas bon
déjà c'est la bonne nouvelle tour des
huit way h4 peut-être
comme dit barron fou
pour ses 8
c'est très très dangereux
prof d'histoire voilà julio taille je
connaissais pas ne connaissait pas
madame chaude et mehdi mon prof
d'histoire était fan d'échecs il
racontait souvent l'histoire de madame
chaud des grandes dames c'est vrai boss
ouais je suis vraiment étonné des coûts
et fabiano en tant que
krka 1 du haut niveau il doit savoir
qu'aujourd'hui en réalité c'est
peut-être lui qui joue bien avec les
noirs
ce dont parlait un magnus hier sur la
partie 2-2 nepomniachi qui après l'avoir
fait tourner n'a pas joué les gains il
pensait que c'était une petite erreur de
la part du joueur russe
si clairement
fabiano c'est un que son adversaire est
peut-être en légère difficulté
elle fera partie s'arrête retour des 8
hours et 8 ici je pense c'est loin à
partir du moment où il a vu sur e4 qui
peut jouer aux 5
il ya un requin souci est ce que eux 5
peut être un coup quand même même sans
avoir été provoqués et là du coup 5 et
moins fort parce que le fou j'ai deux
ans ferme et
j'ai l'impression qu'il va jouer assez
vite fabiano pour moi ce serait un
mauvais coup c'est
l'impression qui va cliquer assez vite
tour à ses 8
avril à l'arrêt dans un fauteuil là le
joueur américain
il est dans un fauteuil
il est extrêmement facile
attention intentions firoud
ça pourrait être la clim aujourd'hui ça
pourrait être la grosse clim
autant dire que s'il perd aujourd'hui le
tournant est réellement terminée pour
pour ali reza alors après il faudra
jouer les places accessit essayé de ne
pas trop perdre de points 2 continue à
prendre de l'expérience
mais à mesa hypothéquerait toute chance
de résultat
ces candidats et là c'est vrai qu'il
réalise simplement une mauvaise partie
pour le muhr
hilairien après quinze coups avec les
blancs même pas une pression il est
moins bien
donc voyais à aucune attaque qu'il fasse
vraiment gaffe ou g5 paraître le
[Musique]
paraître le coup le plus humain pour
essayer de faire nul
on dit si le père aujourd'hui j'avoue
que je ferai une ludwig et arrêterait de
suivre
une vie qui est connu un
attend que tu tourne pas la tête tu es
pas obligé de le laisser comme ça en
tant que tant que tu bouges pas en fait
c'est pas
faut pas oublier qu'elle veut elle avait
failli faire la remonte tadao dernier
candidat je garde espoir pour arriver
d'alireza alors s'il fait nul
aujourd'hui c'est encore possible si
père après il sera il sera quand même
extrêmement loin
il sera quand même extrêmement loin
peut-être trop de half zéro dans la tête
est censé prépa c'est plus le même rôle
est ce que parfois quand tu te prépares
trop théoriquement tu peu moins bien
joué
sur la prêche pas sûr qu'il soit tout le
temps et je le redis
c'est possible ils travaillent beaucoup
de position sur l'échiquier aussi un peu
comme fait qu'un seul
c'est ça qui donne une vraie
compréhension de la position quitte
évite d'utiliser leur dit tu réfléchis
par toi même
plus facile à dire qu'à faire mais en
tout cas c'est ça marche bien pour
carlson un temps sur les autres partis
allez un petit tour
un petit tour et puis s'en va il a joué
dame c5 un ding le dame c5 qu'on
craignait pour icare où
ça pourrait être le jour où finalement
joueurs chinois se réveille
donc ça on en avait déjà parlé ça
pourrait être dangereux radjabov
rapporte
oui juste les blancs peuvent par ok
c'est important mais je sais pas quoi
dire cette position c'est ben y en a
trop un pion quoi un pion de plus c'est
ça un peu plus sport rapporte mais
structure pas terrible du tout et quatre
îlots de pions
forcément beaucoup de cases du coup
logiquement
devrait aller pour les blancs il faut
être précis
donc ça c'est pour la partie radjabov
rapporte et nepomniachi duda et envoie
la sauce
jeu-là sentirez pas trop visuellement
pour duda mais d'un autre côté
il peut y peut-on ce genre de positions
commencent à temps chez nées les
premières lignes jean christophe sellin
très tactique il est très très fort là
dessus c'est son type de position et
après les durs à jouer
on dit carl scène qui sait qu'ali rezaï
capable d'enchaîner victoire après avoir
très mal démarré
il a déjà fait toujours le poing levé
enfin
est ce qui m'inquiète c'est pas vraiment
les défaites c'est que il joue nettement
moins bien sûr la sueur sur cette phase
2 du tournoi partie 4 5 6 ce qu avant il
y avait le mauvais milieu de jeu mais y
avait les belles près pas là il n'y a ni
les prépas nine milieu de jeu
et les deux nouveaux en train de
réfléchir il lui reste plus que 40
minutes
on sait qu'ils jouent chaque coup
après c'est compliqué assez saccadée un
arrêté ça pour pour faire une métaphore
tennistique sa roue c'est un peu mon
niveau tennis quand je frappe la balle
au lieu de continuer dans le mouvement
pour me replacer c'est ça saccade pour
revenir tu perds masse de temps tu perd
du rythme et c'est catastrophique
ça me fait un peu penser à ça la aux
échecs ou tu joues un coup tueur
calcules tu t'arrêtes
cc c'est pas possible en fait on peut
pas jouer comme ça aux échecs
il n'y a pas de rythme en fait
il est pas dans le rythme 26 coup 40
minutes ouais ouais c'est pas facile
hein
il 30 parc ou sinon c'est un énorme
cette note qui arrivent
logiquement à ce rythme là dans six
coups il reste
18 ans même pas
alors après la seule petite chose
rassurante c'est qu'ils avaient été
excellents vins excellents il était
foutue qu'avec les paumés contre les
pots mais quand il lui restait plus que
plus qu'une minute 30 il a commencé à
enchaîner les coups etc la phase de la
partie qu'il a le mieux joué en réalité
ça il a joué avec quatre secondes
parcours qu'il a finalement fini par
lâcher ses coups c'est là qu'il a été le
plus résistant et le plus dangereux
oh lalalalalalalalala
envoyé 1 4 l'ès sahel dans la série va
tenter un all in
ça sent la cata
fait de la conception et j'ai dangereuse
que 4,5
la mach 1 kg 6
aucune menace pour l'adversaire et
maintenant qu'ils avaient les b 4
kg 5 simplement fou prend g5
f6
aucun problème sur cases noires et les
cases blanches je maîtrise tout
c'est le genre de scénario qu'on craint
après c'est pas perdre en classe et
montardon pas du tout
est-ce qu'on peut aussi espérer une
baisse de régime de fabiano aller fabien
dont il nous a peint on va pas dire
habitués mais dernièrement il est
parfois un peu moins précis quand la
position énoncée pas impossible tourner
un peu en sa faveur
cram mixant l'oreillette pour lui dire
que l'on perde les candidats avec classe
c'est pas possible
s'évade inquiet à troll kramnik l'autre
jour là dessus edit j'ai plus loin deux
fois et je les candidats mais il les a
jamais gagné
we dance avec rami qu'en fait c'est le
champion du monde qui est s'est jamais
qualifiée pour un match de championnat
du monde
et échanger du monde grâce à un vice de
procédure voilà caronna qui enchaîne les
bons coups le 5 quasi tempo en plus
et me l'adamant h5 a tempo cette fois-ci
étonnant
j'aurais pu réfléchir à une petite demi
heure
allez c'est peut-être maintenant quand
il va lâcher ses coups qui va devenir le
plus dangereux ali reza
a peut-être qu'il veut une idée avec je
sais pas quand mais dû tout reprendre et
cette fois je crois pour échanger c'est
fou en récupérant la tour après ans et 8
ce serait pas possible suite mais tu
vois en mode scénario n'aurait bougé le
fou on sacrifie rang 17 ont récupéré ses
ouais bien sûr et du coup on pourrait
rester avec les fous de cases noires
peut-être joué sur case sur case noire
justement
l'ordinateur m de moins en moins les
blancs ouais mais bon peut-être qu'il va
mal la conservation et paie pas bonne
forcément
après il peut espérer compliqué que tu
vas rentrer dans une position qui va
bien jouer quoi
10 un requin quand il sent le sens un
tueur il peut jouer tout numéro 1
turbine pendant dix coups c'est le cas
mais davantage non c'est que fabien ne
doit plus viser la nulle de son côté il
doit dire c'est peut-être le moment de
scorer avec les noirs et de revenir sur
mes pots
et ça ça peut être un facteur
intéressant pour ali reza évidemment ce
n'est pas le scénario qu'on espérait
mais
c'est ce qui peut faire que cette partie
se termine sur un résultat
autre que la nulle
vous pensez qu'il est résolu rang
mondial en temps infini
est pas content ni rsa comme sans voix
il agacé ils marchent beaucoup quand on
est mieux
est ce que tu sens qu'il est une grosse
condition physique toi ali reza
rose conditions chez pomme en tout cas
l'espoir d'aller
doit pouvoir s'améliorer at
il fait du sport le matin pendant les
tournois
n'ont
pas fait
et tu sais s'ils pratiquent un sport
d'hommes bien il aime bien le ping pong
on l'a fait jouer un peu avec nous m'ont
donné un peu trop fort
et je crois qu'ils
basket un petit peu aussi
ping pong ses pinceaux
pas faux
après le tennis et la même chose sauf
que tu es debout sur la table comme
dirait coluche
ding adorent le basket
en chine c'est populaire le bas ce cas
d'un oui yao yao ming
yao ming ne sait plus comment il
s'appelait ce joueur de m 32
un beau match cornetto
m 31
ding joue beaucoup au basket ni maxime
est ce qu'il est bon
il est pas grand pourtant digne non non
après meneur de jeu tu peux aux basques
atteint pas obligés d'être très grand ou
après les pas pro 1 qui fait
c'est chaud pour duda non m'at on y
passait il ya une petite minute sur duda
ça paraissait chaud mais c'est encore
vrai nom c'est choquant lordier pas
affolée mais oui
ça donne pas envie quoi
alors prends danger cinq top a envie tu
penses tu te fais maths est
donc grand achille
gauche on dit
juste qu'il arrive à poursuivre son
attaque c'est un
solide chelem pour les noirs
ce que f5 avec 5 et le pion
donc si y'a pas f5 comme ya de plus 5
qui reste en prise c'est solide encore
pas facile way
est ce que tu peux pas attaquer vraiment
sur la colonne tu te prends le retour de
bon goût là
donc c'est passé pas si clair on nous
dira porte c'est chaud est ce qu'il ya
eu du nouveau dans radjabov rapporte
quel est des deux tours promet de
à
la tour en b2 fous
ces bosses pour aller chercher un tour
pour un f2 tour prend b2 avec un roi
très très faible et donc il a fait f3
il va se prendre un tour f ii roi j'ai
un fou c'est 5
je comprends j'ai quatre tours f4 jeu
mais la ligne de la turbine à tout ce
qu'elle paraît logique
ouais c'est chaud difficile à évaluer en
fait
ça peut jouer des deux côtés mais bon on
connaît sans fin connaissant la
dynamique des deux joueurs tu dis
rapport doit quand même être très
favoris dans ce genre de position
position passive quand même pour les
pour le blanc et les deux tours
ouais complexe
complexe et nakamura ding dame c5 ça
commence à réfléchir à ça en fait ça
pourrait faire trois victoires au noir
quasiment aujourd'hui
tout cas pour le monde ding rapporte et
caruana
semble
être légèrement devant avec les noirs ce
qui est quand même assez rare un aux
échecs seb à la sortie d ouverture comme
ça après 1h30 2h de jeu d'avoir les
trois positions noir deux heures et demi
dieu d'avoir les trois positions noir
légèrement supérieur c'est rare
c'est très surprenant après bon on peut
voir quand même qu'il ya deux joueurs
qui sont pas théoriciens qui souffre
donc radjabov
je coiffe et théoricien mais voilà ils
travaillent moins maintenant et nakamura
qui n'est pas du tout et oritia
donc deux joueurs qui sont là c'était
c'était pas une énorme surprise et par
rapport à fear hodja bombail est tombé
il tombe sur
sur du très très solide un qui fait
aucune erreur
il un peu rentrer dans la gueule du loup
aussi avec une prépa
surprise et mais il s'est auto surpris
je dirais il s'est auto dribbler en fait
donc là clairement s'ils jouent cavalia
un bon c'est un aveu de catastrophe
donc floue g5 1
ils recommencent à réfléchir on peut se
remettre en grand ouais ça va vraiment
pas du tout elle aime pas du tout sa
position
alors ce choix de catalan un petit peu à
contre style elle fuji sien qui à foug
projet simplement
car elle les prend et h 6
c'est très triste
c'est tour ses cinq tours c'est 8
as tu as l'impression vaz et c'est
neymar qui pardon des passements de
jambes et il oublie le ballon quoi
ça donne vraiment cette impression là ce
que ce que fait les résas dans cette
partie
ah ouais c'est une très mauvaise chose
ça va être méchant ce que je vais dire
j'ai l'impression que c'est une partie
de mon niveau là avec les blancs pour le
moment
c'est un peu mon niveau de jeu quoi je
te cache pas
c'est pour ça que j'ai arrêté d'ailleurs
là c'est une partie ça ressemble un peu
à ça j'en sors je me demande pourquoi je
joue aux échecs tu attends royal yacht
qu'elle faudra penser à arrêter
sa part dans les insultes way
ça ressemble à ce que je fais quoi une
nouveauté à deux balles et après des
pièces qui partent vers le roi comme ça
qu'ils font là et c'est tout à fait moi
ça
et après tu regrettes
en ce concerne les olympiades 2024
d'ailleurs ouais je lui dis pas
ça c'est intéressant quand je vois les
parties comme ça je te vois je préfère g
sélectionneur à côté tu vois je peux me
libérer ce sera ou de j'imagine comme
souvent ouais juillet-août ouais il ya
déjà une endroit annoncé déjà renoncé
sait pas on sait pas encore je viens si
jamais il faut pas ça te plaise here
non je reste pas en touche sur le
commentaire là oui je devais faire une
simultanée à
le 25 qui samedi
malheureusement j'ai dû annulé pour des
raisons personnelles et en fait bon le
truc personnel ne s'est pas passé donc
bon
[Rires]
c'est magnifique ah bah oui mais je suis
j'en suis le principal perdant
ça devait se faire voir mon peu importe
c'est un truc truc médical voilà rien de
grave rien de grave c'est le plus
important donc donc voilà c'est pour ça
que j'ai préféré faire annuler
simultanée au cas où le truc et lieu
alors un prune c'était sur l'autre truc
ok pardon
sur le niveau de quel niveau de cave est
très bon
au 8 le dire
c'est une catastrophe
ces insectes
fallu
à la la
est ce que tu as déjà fait le test de
santé ont nommé un coton tige dans
l'urètre
non je demande aux gens comme ça c'est
c'est pour faire peur en fait
si tu as a fait un peu bref si en plus
les gens dans le chat du coup réagissent
un peu ça fait un peu peur à tout le
monde
moi j'ai déjà eu à le faire et en russie
malheureusement c'est assez particulier
ouais ouais c'est pour lancer un petit
débat pour que ça réagisse un peu dans
le chat ça allait mais toujours très mal
des gens ça parce que quand tu connais
l'existence d'un tel truc qui pensaient
1 que le fait d'y penser ça te fait déjà
mal non je suis là
mainguy pensais tu vois ça ah ouais pas
les gens qui sont mal et on dise n'est
pas gagnant allez ça commence à être un
peu à bouger en cette journée
olalalala mais c'est fou c'est d'avoir
pris alors il a échangé et qu'est ce que
tu fais contre le plan
ce que tu fais quand le plan d' attaque
d'un match alors celui-là à la mairie la
foulée 4 donc là tu prends prend la f5
jeu
ah ouais tour f4 carrément en plus j'ai
su ce qu'est une pièce ah oui à djezzy
ceci ouvre
aussi ses pions pranger 6e
à ménéz peau qui peut
et pau qui nous refait la même
mais nenê peau il veut vraiment y
retourner en fait c
est ce que tu penses que né peau préfère
jouer contre carlson ou faire le test de
du coton tige dans l'urètre on préfère
c'est pas sûr
franchement coton tige dans l'urètre ça
passe en fait un bond de dépôt c'est un
compétiteur hors norme quoi
les retournant il s'en fout après si je
peux me permettre ça ressemblait à coton
tige aussi mais pas dans l'urètre
carlson très honnêtement tu vois dans
l'urètre et paco et pacsés ça
c'était double en fait
ça craque c'est complètement fini bomba
points un point ici un mais c'est
incroyable il va être à plus trois mais
comme dans les premiers appareils +36
parti
c'est quand même très impressionnant
ok donc là on va avoir un bon voilà
c'est sur le rattrapa beckham et ktf
cinq niveaux qui sont sans rire hier par
un trou de souris entre guillemets rien
duda com - il est l'un il est pas bien à
sa santé
est primée par sa position
ça s'appelle et l'aude c'est le look
quoi est exactement la même posture que
contre ali reza contraintes et gagner
très tranquille
on pourra pas lui enlever qui sait
gagner les candidats répondent sais pas
s'il ira au bout mais en tout cas il a
la recette
olala il sait rien à ces terribles
difficile difficile hadji
rajhi et ben et koutiala exactement la
variante qu'on a montré au préalable
c'est exactement ce qu'on regardait et
là alors didonne cavaliers 3
fallait changer le maximum de pièces
très important ça peut encore tenir pour
radjabov
il ya le fable qui est en train de
revenir enac a contredit ou l'inca qui
plombe un ouf ce que dams et 5 ça fait
bien une demi heure
on pourrait avoir une journée avec
quatre victoires je pense
c'est mauvais mauvais signe pour nous on
aimerait bien qu'il en ait que trois je
crois
c'est parce que alireza ou plus que 27
minutes d'ailleurs on a oublié c'est la
cata le regarder s'il ya trop
franchement tu joues les candidates et
comme ça après 15 koulaté et ait été
touché éric huard et way
est complètement écoeuré
on a mis chakir venu nous voir
annoncée c'est la pire partie ouais
c'est la pire partie remise et recel
contre dépôt était pas terrible marsala
avec les blancs
hier c'était presse était c'était de
mauvais présage par six candidats qui
était
de très mauvaise facture
on peut pas le rappeler pour jouer les
olympiades là dans deux semaines
il fallait envoyer un petit sms
la pub est très content de lui et c est
ce que je vais envoyer frérot qui est
candidat on essaye de gagner les
olympiades dans trois sphères
base est content qu'ils ont
annoncé eux
c'est la soupe à l'ail ah ça y est vous
j'ai la tête à la la la la regarde
hays sait qui va gagner
des petits shot libye ou pas
non
disent que tu as oublié
après
un petit goûter ou pas
oh là là
à l'intendance et de basse qualité
aujourd'hui
t'as pas l'air bien
en fait j'ai fermé
il va y avoir quatre victoires
dont trois noirs
c'est très très mauvais coton il pouvait
faire nul encore s'il y jouer quatre
échanges et la sai
wan en casino peut-être trouvé quoi tu
résides fab
ah oui fans qui étaient quand même pas
bien d'avoir oublié
[Rires]
il a su et quand même j'ai oublié
je fécales taille pour des maillots et
du coude et où dit je fais à l os x elle
plutôt xl en ce moment chez xl
lequel le quintal le quintal oui oui
c'est très athlétique
je suis dégoûté en fait enfin les
candidats je les attendais schnell de
vente et alireza il va me faire mal et
où ils apprécieront de serre et une
série d'autres il ya quoi il y aurait
deux points et demi de retard
pour hydro car
franchement ça dégoûtant
mais aucun talent athlétique ouais non
mais un critique
très athlétique non oui bien sûr mais
bon là j'ai bien mangé quand même
récemment top-12 c'est dur toute forme
top 12 un peu lâché les fours
deux ans mangent beaucoup ont fait pas
tant de sport que ça
elle va redevenir numéro un français et
oui ça va être le jeu des chaises
musicales pour cette première place il
semblait après le grand suisse et sur
pina d'europe italie reza avait pris le
dessus sur lvl mais papy fait de la
résistance
je commençais à avoir chaud même et j'ai
dû fermer parce que ça pis pleuvait des
trombes d'eau
john mack s'arrête
c'est terrible
fabiano la bête noire des français
la maxime qui va nous rejoindre dans une
petite dizaine de minutes
on espère la rencontre entre nostra
planus et nostra planus
dans dix minutes les raisins il y aura
douze minutes à la pendule
un nouvel va se qualifier pour les
candidat j'en suis persuadé moi
non je pense que cet échec
à faire une sorte d'effet touche le fond
en fait je rebondis il ya aussi ça et
puis aussi le facteur que je suis
convaincu que les grandes chaînes tour
c'est parfait pour notre sport fait pour
lui j attends tous les a tous les ans il
fait top 3 mais il faut y parvient ça va
être
dur il va se qualifier du coup pour les
candidats facilement il va arriver aux
candidats hyper soulagé et là
évidemment expériences de tous les temps
il ya deux ans
même s'il avait très bien joué au final
deux ans
ouais mais c'est différent c'est
différent mais fait un score un premier
candidat c'est tout à fait décent
quatre victoires comme sur 14 parties
complètement
pour maxime l'est et surtout les deux
tournois qui ont eu lieu les deux
derniers mois qui était très important
en fait bizarrement oui bien sûr la
halle après après déception
il ya eu un peu l'art et la réussite
qu'il a eue là c'est un peu la réussite
qu'il a pas eu malheureusement au grand
prix fidh ouais c'est clair
tu te rappelles cette partie contrat
porte qu'on a vus ensemble à
elle me saoule encore d'y penser de
cette partie là parce que
ça joue tellement à rien ce jeu
si roux déjà il est tellement mal mais
ouais il a hier je suis allée est
complètement déprimée je reconnais soit
être même effet une partie de merde la
can
d'angola s'il le sait on le sait
lui-même il est pas content
[Musique]
il ya plein de faim faim tu joues pas
quatre comme 4 c'est un coude et pas en
forme le 4 c'est pas un jeu c'est parce
qu'on pensera maxime mais
ça tu te bloque complètement
maximale a dit qu'il avait pensé à
calais f3 bon ok mais je ne sais pas qui
tu veux jouer 4 à castres
regarde me fait la moue aller le le
temps plus viejo déjà tu le vois rien
qui lie sur lui quand il est mort là je
peux te dire que caronna est très très
en confiance
je fais une partie niveau de kev
parti de merde
il doit pas se sentir bien
mais là il va je le fous g5 où il peut
jouer cavalier peut-être nous dynepo +61
et pau s'est finie mais dépôt le tenait
plus la nuda n'est plus là
va devoir prendre et c'est de sacrifier
les pièces mais réelle 5 dame prend b2
c'est quoi c'est peut-être d'approuver
deux qui étaient pourris ou quoi
si cette
36e journée de gagner sont non non non
c'est pas fait encore
est ce que n'a qu'a fini par jouer
toujours pas
d'un cas il va arriver quasiment alors
de réflexion dans cette position pierrot
il parle français mais
l'époux duda radjabov rapporte il faut
trois tons projet 4 devrait la tenir
quand même
radjah de justesse à les faux cuir ou
sauvons - le demi point tu peux te dire
il aura les blancs comptent radjabov
charmante à 50% fin
qui sauve le nippon là il faut il faut
s'accrocher
pour rester en vie dans ce tournoi
a complètement sombré à jour de repos tu
peux récupérer la dynamique
troisième temps de tournoi et pas
forcément la même que celle du premier
du deuxième ouais en fait il faut être
faut être accrochés au wagon pas trop
loin
il espérait peut-être une chute devant
away genre juste qu'il tombe en fait je
pense à ceux qui t'ont quoi tu es là
apple avait eu ce gala en patinage de
vitesse a gagné les demi finales et la
finale car 15 à carhaix car demi finale
lités dernier à chaque fois
incroyable
disait il va arriver au 20e coup avec
moins de dix minutes il faisait 5
ans que fabiano va rejouer assez vite
quand même
10 minutes max à mon avis
il va jouer
tu prends g5
tu peux pas t'amuser à faire autre chose
sinon tu perds
15.27 va prendre six jours la séquence
villageois prise à chis retour du
cavalier en
f3
on n'a pas de problème
tu protèges le pion à 5
pour ces cinq
à trois
dîners a détruit son avantage
il a joué trop vite l'impression
j'avais ce coup qui apparemment s'était
vraiment +61 temps ces trois
pour prendre cette ne fonctionnait pas
parce qu'il y avait dame prend 17
gagne une qualité et même si tu manges
un pion au no 5 cd matin
trois plus un ça fait 4 et devant ça
vaut 5
on demande ce qu'est ce que doit se dire
carlson là à mon avis
la carlsson la 10e pour le moment il
trouve que ça joue mal
rien on peut quand même dire par rapport
aux autres candidats
pour le moment en tout cas pour le
moment
allez un coup tempo qui a rallié pranger
5 on prend ça fait du bien
menaces m'attendais quand même seb a
s'étaient vus
on pourra quand même se dire qu'il est
passé à un coût de la victoire
trop tôt
[Musique]
mais même dans son étude dont ils vous
ces coups là et tout bas je sais pas
lire
le langage corporel ya rien qui va
mary caronna qui a vu le matin les amis
il a fait mal
est-ce que la canicule peut jouer
d'ailleurs
sur
très dur avec la chaleur
même si j'imagine qu'il ya la clim dans
la salle de jeu tu as subi quand même la
challe vie et tu subis et dans son hôtel
dans tu vas manger au restaurant tu
subis
top 16 ans moi j'ai un jour j'étais un
peu moins bien acheté à vous tout chaud
chaud hein
tu sors du sort la partie à cette heure
il fait 40 degrés puis la cli n'y a pas
tout le monde la supporter pareille
voilà qui déteste
les iraniens les galas cher ça devrait
aller voici ce qu'on pensait avant mais
ça veut rien dire en fait enfin
après lui les chartrains à chaleur
vraiment
qu'il vient de vivre du côté de chez
nous
bon après la position elle n'est pas
perdue je pense que si tu joues tous les
meilleurs qu avec les blancs tu as quand
même tiré ton demi point ici c'est juste
que c'est le scénario de la partie qui
fait penser qu'il y arrivera pas plus
qu'autre chose en fait scénario a tué
dix jours une partie là avec
avec deux résultats ça qui est qui
l'embêtent
soir était extraordinaire que caruana
loupé le match en un vrai ça aurait été
beau
n'a pas dit que c'était fini on a juste
dit que pour le moment ce qu'a laissé
six très bien joué
pourquoi ce coup est très bien joué en
fait parce que ils bloquent le cavalier
f3
kf3 ne peut plus bouger
le cari vient s'imposer en d4 est donc
là la question et c'est bonne chance
pour trouver un plan avec les avec les
blancs parce qu'il n'a pas
en faire qu est-ce que qu'est ce que
fait la petite turbine il fait un
travail fait à trois mais quatre ans ben
watson a pas de plan donc le tu tentes
tu prends un peu d espace un peu de
cases noires fois je crois peut-être
copains fois je crois tout de suite
jusqu'à 8 mb cas tu parlais du matériel
donc à 3
à troyes est logique à trois ça fait un
double sens étroit et très logique tu
contrôles les cases noires tu mettais
pions sur la couleur opposée à ton flou
beaucoup de choses qui paraissent comme
très utile dans ses dépositions
là encore il va arriver encore
pioché dans sa maigre réserve de temps
il a moins d'une minute par coup
maintenant donc il faut qu'il lâche ses
coups il n'y a pas de 30 secondes par
coup ici seul il peut réfléchir un
cavalier h4 mais bon j'y crois vraiment
pas du tout cas vous lâcher ses coups
les faux-pas faut pas avoir des regrets
d'avoir d'avoir l'impression de juste
pas avoir joué une partie du jeu
d'échecs
qui joue simple ne peut pas jouer des
coups compliqué il reste vingt coups à
jouer avec son son quart d'heure il faut
jouer à trois
voyages 4 c'est beaucoup trop compliqué
pont
puis surtout quand le car il viendra en
aide 5 même les blancs et noirs pour
manger installé qu'ayant des quatre ans
j'aime quand j'en f5 damev 6,24
tellement de choix à troyes b 4 sa part
et ben c'est pas grandiose allez alireza
à 3
il croque un petit coup d'oeil nerveux à
la pendule d'ailleurs au passage 15
minutes t'as même pas rêver mieux de jeu
cette
guerre je le vois pas boire d'eau
alors ouais alors lui la doré ou en
slovénie c'était la banane
banane et
après quand il se lève normands ils ont
un petit coin même et enfin vu le temps
qui reste à six qui s'hydratent ac en
réalité pas tu as apparaître des détails
mais c'est quand même des choses
importantes aussi on ne voit pas avoir
de
sais pas si vous l'avez vu boire moi
j'ai pas fait attention
ça qui restent assis très longtemps il a
même pas un verre d'eau à côté une
bouteille
on l'a vu boire des petites gorgées mais
big boi peu non les bois peut
cesser des détails mais c'est des
détails qui ont leur importance
une bouteille caché ouais mais bon
on va pas s'alimenter don quichotte pour
repartir
à le choc gengembre fait du bien on
empêche notre hall même en même en
partie c'est pas mal ça te met un petit
coup de fouet
ça repart enfin ça repart comme tous les
jours si lloris 17 minutes 30 au monde
qui sait si la moindre minute park où il
reprend 4 ou 5 milles sur un vous comme
à troyes qui est quand même se fait tant
il veut pas chercher un type b 4
c'est le coup de l'ordi b 4 mai à troyes
c'est le coup ses coûts en blitz et puis
tu sens que c'est pas là le
tout autre
ou alors tu envoies des quatre comme ça
ta peau tu cliques quoi mais il faut
cliquer
il faut vraiment qu'ils prennent pas qui
comme seconde en fait deux trois coups
au hasard à certains moments dans la
partie
est hors des cinq faut aussi c'est un
coup d'épée dans l'eau autour des 5
grands là il y aurait un mur tu as il se
prendrait une calotte mémorable après la
partie
alors ouais ça va pas
juste jouer un coup du jeu d'échecs
c'est un conseil simple mais
quelques peut-être comprendre et cette
fois je crois mais j'y crois tellement
pas
la dame en d3
tu ne peux rien dire il l'aurait fait
pire parce que tu aurais fait pire que
tu peux rien dire
sinon il y aurait plus de coach de rien
parce que tu joue moins bien que tu peux
pas aider les joueurs à progresser
et à
gommer leur leurs défauts
malèye panique en fait juste
ouais j'ai paniqué chef
est pas bon tout ça
c'est terrible oui la jaquette ouais
ouais
un trop prompt 17 donc en effet le
salaire catastrophique
ouah c'est 1 1 c'est sa tour d un qui va
partir
l'ordi déteste parce qu'il y avait cinq
est pas facile f5 un jockey
dam des trois ça suffit pas pour de
38,05 ap
hockey
plutôt un bon coup en fait f5 dur à
jouer parce que des f 5 tu sais pourquoi
il va pas le jouer je pensais pas que je
laisse l'initiative à ahfir où il veut
quoi
même si à rien en fait mais il le fera
pas
rien bon alors on va voir longue longue
longue réflexion là il a vu
là il a vu f5 c'est sûr il a vu f5 dames
8e 6 kudo tu vois tu vois l'expérience
et maintenant ça va calculer car le
festival des très chic lé là tu voir sa
surface
voilà ça y est c'est parti à parti
hajjar 20 minutes de voilà les joues pas
jusqu'à 27 jusqu'à 30 minutes j'utilise
voilà ça y est
ça commence à calculer on le connaît
fabiano
[Rires]
aie aie
là ça va être le bal
un ca y est ils voient un petit peu
alireza enfin allez y sans qui lui a
fait mal là c'est bien
gras tation important et voit la famille
qui va nous faire tout son répertoire
il en a beaucoup des positions
il a fait cette la
maxime qui va nous rejoindre alors
attends on va préparer ça
va mettre un petit maxime ambulant en
bas à droite on va cacher de chasse
comme en fait
ça doit pas embêtés rennes juste un nom
tu me rassures
j'avais peur ça le gêne
c'est mathieu cornette c'est pas la
bonne personne
ouais
on va demander à maxime tiens d'ailleurs
ce qu'ils en pensent quand il est en
phase de fabiano 2 de son répertoire
de position
sadr est assez chiant
j'ai fait un truc qui pourrait vraiment
le déconcentrer mais bon il peut mal le
prendre c'est de faire exactement les
mêmes positions puis en face de lui ça
c'est insupportable
je te fais pareil fait exactement la
même chose je pense que tu fais péter un
plomb en fait
miroir miroir ouais
je pense si tu fais ça ça le rend fou
c'est
pas donné l'idée à maxime il est capable
de le faire
on va [ __ ] la merde avec ça
alors attends une maxime qui arrive
tiens je te donne un écouteur
on va essayer de se mettre comme ça
faire ce qu'on peut
dire on va casser le truc pour avoir
plus de distance sur
géant va récupérer maximum avec la
caméra
y salue max est ce que tu alors attends
une petite seconde max je dois mettre
ton audio
pour compte entendent
vas-y ouais c'est bon tu entends année
là ça va
assez dur
il fait chaud sur paris aussi fait lourd
à y fais pas ci chômé
on a participé launay voilà voilà en
fait son appart c'est simple je
multiplie la température par deux
ans quand il fait 20 il fait 40
ouais
j'ai passé des nuits très compliqué dans
son ya paderne mais c'était en retour de
baden
d'ouvrir la fenêtre je peux fermer les
volets le matin ça change
alors comment tu vis et ses candidats
toi maxime
mike août c'est un peu bizarre les
parties pas se mentir c'est sûr que vos
fins pour moi la leçon numéro un c'est
évidemment un joueur
a besoin d'être en confiance je vais te
dire j'ai connu ça sur la deuxième
partie des candidats ou après vas y que
gm veut travailler
autant que je vais
les coups se lâchaient pas et c'est vrai
que au final ce tournoi de bucarest qui
est un tournoi de préparation de halle
ali reza pages jaunes depuis six mois
s'est pas très bien passé
et ça n'a peut-être perturbé ouais pas
pas aisé par son adversaire de la
dernière l'art d'ailleurs après on a
tous les exemples 1 c'est à dire que
fabiano il avait gagné un tournoi des
candidats pour avoir fait leur travail
kendy
difficile way est ce que toi ça ça ça te
donne tu as tu un petit pincement au
coeur de paillettes rouges je dois je me
demande quand est ce que je vois tu
regardes est parti large pourri ça
change rien en fait j'ai
autant certaines années je n'étais pas
qualifié
comment la ou arrogant suisse et à la
limite à la coupe du monde ça match
qu'il est très chaud il peut très bien
tourné en ma faveur mais bon ça reste
être les huitièmes de finale
même si après
8e ça reste ça reste assez loin de la
finale on pourra ensuite je n'étais pas
si loin mais pas si proche de plus été
la même si la dernière je n'aurais pas
été qualifiés et au grand prix fidh j'ai
été pour la première fois depuis
longtemps assez catastrophique
voilà après évidemment
qu'intrinsèquement je veux dire il ya
beaucoup de joueurs qui s'ils s'étaient
qualifiés pour les candidats auraient
clairement pu aussi bien joué ou voir
que certains joueurs
à dire non mais c'était pour pour je ne
suis pas qualifié j'ai pas c'est tout
non mais c'est pour avoir ton ressenti
tout va le ressenti d'un joueur de haut
niveau forcément nous on l'a pas
puisqu'on est des petits joueurs quoi
donc on se demande tu vas quand toi tu
regardes tu as et un petit pape un
pincement au coeur mais ouais ce côté là
donc illimités mais ce mélange vraiment
le pincement au coeur c'est vraiment en
2018 voire même en 2016 parce que en
2015 j'avais extrêmement performant un
peu trop tard
je performais extrêmement bien j'étais
est forcément des médias si j'ajoute au
mot des candidats
aurait pu être une autre histoire
pareille
cheveux voilà et d'ailleurs ça c'est
pendant le samson 2018 jamais une
voie là mais ça donne envie quand tu
quand tu vois le tournant à la gym age
in que
vu le niveau de jeu en plus cela que tu
as pu réafficher quand même dans tes
dernières sorties ça doit d'autant plus
de donner envie d'y retourner parce que
comme tu le disais n'était pas forcément
au dessus des autres et pas en dessous
non plus quoi sa sas comme disait abbas
et vlad qui disait j'ai bien aimé il
emploie une expression que c'est un peu
le carrousel des numéros 2 mondiaux j'ai
bien aimé l'expression web a été
longtemps semblé
assez compliqué il ya même rarement une
bataille deuxième vous avez été si cette
non bah alors j'étais caruana à rognan
so
mois
rogers ging trisha
dintrich au mas m mais c'est sûr ils
choisissent urvoas et 8 déjà riche que
je suis pas sûr je suis quasi sûr great
choc mais a peut-être c'était la numéro
3 n'a été dit je suis pas sûr mais je
suis d'ailleurs très long mais je pense
que
je dirais
7,2 g ne suis pas sur saône oui avec
ramener des sites électricité crown et
queer
et il y en a qu à peut-être à nantes à
l'est la cage 3 c'était pendant deux
trois jours non un truc comme ça
peut-être que oui publiez pas sur mes
lives writing quasiment parce que je
crois qu'il en a parlé donc il y n'y va
pas rater une occasion de dire un ca c
est à nantes de possibles
[Musique]
et les vannes va la cité aussi les
modestes en restant 1er mai
kasparov la mi-temps le che prix sont
complètement il craque complètement
et donc et firoud déjà là qu'est ce que
tu en penses de la question qu'on se
pose depuis cinq-six jours de deux de
ses réflexions gestion gwan ah bah c'est
pas bon ça c'est sûr un classeur pour le
coup
j'ai toujours été sérieux irréprochable
bon alors là ils vont laisser partir non
mais alors lire et au chant non parce
que parfois ça m'arrive à même de jouer
trop vite ah oui oui non sens seul frein
1.5 du
web après 5 carmona iceq d une occase de
gagner il ya n'est pas en face à côté
qui regarde je sais pas ce que ça donne
mais bon dans son esprit est déjà gagné
marty même si c'est peut-être dans le
cas maintenant
aux grandes occasions et
restent
donc ouais anyresa il a déjà montré un
scepticisme en termes de gestion du
temps le saurez ce qu'est lui caresse
mais aussi sur d'autres pour moi il aime
bien prendre son temps après
la gestion du temps que j'avais à 18 ans
n'était pas la même qu'à la 22e ni qu'à
14 mika disant
même eu des périodes moi je
comme six ans je jouais à toutes les
parties en cinq minutes donc voilà il ya
toujours un équilibre à trouver
peut-être que alireza n'a pas encore
trouvé notamment parce que certains
jouets principalement sur internet
[Musique]
voilà il ya peut-être aussi des réflexes
a trouvé enfin après voilà on a vérité
d'un tournoi
[Musique]
n'ont pas joué sur les mots
n'est pas la vérité pour l'avenir
ouais non mais clairement mais il ya
quelque chose qui va pas alors est ce
que des parfois ça peut aussi venir d'un
trop trop de trop de pression qui vous
qui fait déjouer
malartre pression
non mais c'est plutôt ton ressentent
mois la limite j'ai presque un milliard
d'euros pression me faire jouer trop
vite
en délit de fuite après ouais voilà
encore une fois moi j'ai jamais problème
pour prendre une décision et j'ai une
règle à laquelle
je ne déroge cas sinon jamais c'est si
je mets plus de vingt minutes pour
rejoindre
faut que je le joue parce que de toute
façon dont je consomme plus il ya de
chances que ce soit un mauvais
d'ailleurs simple
c'est un peu ce qui se passe
vraiment au top 16 se passer une fois
j'ai réfléchi
c'était le mauvais
c'est un peu la règle du clic au hasard
kit est enseignée par baky aussi un os
alors même pas que
j'avais pris de l'avancé
sur hazard qui restent calmes une
spécialité pakistanaise
corps
je pense que pour le coup bas qui
accordera à
l'origine du petit oiseau au maire pour
le co est gelée inspiré j'ai inspiré le
pakistan oui oui on sait avec le niveau
clic au hasard tu te défends pas mal
mais bon le hasard fait souvent bien les
choses et ouais bah il va falloir
apprendre cette cette magie alireza
qu'il a peut-être plus sur internet en
boulettes
web aller piger hilarité comme tous les
ans nice alors autant pas mal en soi
mais c'est vrai que il a perdu certains
réflexes à avoir
encore une fois
on dise rien quand
le voir le contraire quand il marchait
sur l'eau
un autre nom mais après j'ai envie de
dire du coup ça m'a fait penser que
c'est quand même la différence
fondamentale
français
je le pense c'est une des différences
fondamentales mais c'est les autres et
que bon quand on est en confiance
tous que ce soit tous les joueurs qu'on
a cité deux l'iresa les bonnes moi même
sow
un bref mais maniche a
jamais été numéro 2 mondial peut tous se
hisser au niveau carsen et même le
dépasser
mais par contre
quand et la symbolique se matérialisent
très facilement
quand manu sera un tournoi c'est à dire
dans le niveau de jeu il perd jamais la
confiance dans son jeu intrinsèque et
donc il va malgré tout lâcher ses coups
peu importe il a fait la partie d'avant
[Musique]
c'est pas forcément toujours vrai mais
en tout cas il a cette confiance de se
dire
que même quand ils jouent mal même quand
objectivement il n'est pas de meilleur
joueur du monde sur ce tournoi il se dit
quand même je suis meilleur joueur du
monde donc je viens de conte et 7e pour
jouer pour lâcher mes coups c'est aussi
la marque des très grands en ans on peut
dire un truc interne a fait ça de toute
façon ça fait
je travaille ça c'est peut-être voilà et
malheureusement c'est sûr qu'au grand
prix fidh
deuxième partie un
peu défaut
mais si si je m'étais dit que j'y
arriverai quand même
passé je sais pas c'est toujours après
ouais objectivement je jouerai je jouais
trop mal à ce moment là et c'est
difficile d'être toujours au niveau et
ça et ça dans tous les sports
ça dans tous les sports bien sûr où est
nommé la confiance
et je suis en confiance
c'est un peu un peu dangereux ouais
ouais voilà donc c'est quand même
[Musique]
dans
l'ain à qui dirait 100 % du réseau la
confiance
non mais je veux dire c'est à dire que
dans l'album en confiance
ne peut pas mal joué
et même s'il va mal joué un coup il va
se remettre à
flot oui et puis tu mets une pression je
sais pas il ya un truc inexplicable qui
se passe qui doit être dans le langage a
en plus offert à dire que non seulement
tu es en confiance donc toujours mieux
non plus ton adversaire secte en
confiance
des jouets en retour et tu vois tu peux
faire une faute
faute de calcul maxime et paf du coup ne
punit pas mais complètement cessé
complètement ça et puis c'est aussi le
côté des
machins de pas je cherche moment ce
communiquera ce comics ans merci merci
seb qui fait que que tu joues bien tu
fais un peu moins bien joué l'autre qui
lui se retrouve un peu moins en
confiance et à combien de matchs de
tennis qui tombe comme ça
passe à un moment donné à la balle elle
est bonne il met deux fois le coup droit
croisé deux fois là bas elle tombe sur
la ligne
après la différence entre les échecs
aux échecs toujours une partie tennis
tant que faire changer oui le court le
cours des choses mais alors que tu fais
une fois deux échecs c'est fini tu
schématise tu m'as coup droit dans le
filet smash filet
[Musique]
à 5 5
mai
mais bon sauf si c'est sûr
tu peux perdre un jeu un certain talent
droit de perdre un jeu ou un set c'est
pas grave oui mais non là aux échecs tu
peux pas mais d'où l'emportant 6 d'être
en confiance parce que quand tu es en
confiance tu vas jouer un peu plus vite
aussi parce que tu veux un peu moins
recalculé ce que tu as vu parce que
c'est ça change tout aussi et c'est ça
après ouais déjà aux jeux de rome
clairement il prenait bien son temps
médian est passé tanking qui nous a fait
alors après voilà je suis pas non plus
si défaitiste même pour cette partie
même s'il est moins bien là il a repris
mme à dire le contrôle de la situation
si justement au prix justement d'autres
venir vraiment bien il a le contrôle de
la position dans son schéma là un peu
paradoxal mais
voilà après si on ne trouve plus ou ses
rideaux et voilà mais bon
donc il va pouvoir jouer assez vite
assez bien quand même s'il a des boues
instinct
note n'est pas mal non
plus quand même faire étalage de sa
classe donc elle n'est pas finie cette
partie 13 ce qui peut même la gagne et
d'après toi
si la situation se retourne et qui
conserve l'initiative
oui
mes fans je trouves tu me tues me contre
à dire à 6,6 g temps mais je trouve que
depuis allé depuis le son match
championnat du monde contre carl scène
il nous a habitués alors pas dans toutes
les parties mais a laissé un peu ce
genre de position filet en faisant une
grosse à une grosse faute une faute
importante à
certains moments décisifs
mais pas que lui c'est ce genre de
position franchement ce genre de
position
je suis dire j'ai même envie de dire que
même menus sont pas tous les jouer à la
perfection
donc
souvent cédé situation tu vois le
potentiel d'attac pour les blancs et
donc tout moment tu te prépare
mentalement à faire machine arrière si
si ça tourne mal en fait
donc tu te retrouves à jouer un petit
peu entre deux quoi c'est ça même si tu
sais que tu es mieux alors après la demi
heure d'avancé
et une différence nathan et galeux
presque certain que fabiano sera en mode
je sais même pas si fabiano aurait joué
tu penses qu'ils profitent de son
avantage autant pour
après objectivement cesser les meilleurs
coups mais
et voilà encore une fois il y à la
position qu'ils avaient d'abord atik
mail a des chances de faire une grosse
erreur au blanc sont relativement
faibles même avec peu de temps
alors que les chances de faire une
erreur au noir qui priverait de l'avoir
neutralisé son avantage mais ensuite
le faire retomber enfin même s'est
retourné la partie la défense des noirs
sont
relativement élevés enfin je me tire
comparativement corps voilà
elle a joué le coût supposé être le bon
vieux 4 way non mais bien sûr je veux
dire c'est pas qu'un coup qu'il faut
trouver oui bon il va finir par craquer
je veux très vite l'alerté en tout cas
on n'a plus le choix il a plus le choix
et
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il a juste 17
ans dix ans maintenant mais plus facile
à jouer à la place sinon c'est vrai que
tu laisses faire fois ci ce machin je
veux la case
alors la dame f7 je pensais
alors je pensais pas qualifiés si ce
fait je pense à damas leur mode
psg il a plus le choix il reste que ce
soit joué à dix restent donc il doit
cliquer
donc là il donne le pion à 2 donc
évidemment objectivement d'autres
concours
2 mai
alors qu'elle peut être des dames mi
raisin les
requérants sont les a manqué cinq mois
je voyais d'amener 5 aussi alors qu'elle
existe peut-être
mais plus tard aussi puisque j'ai envie
de pouvoir avoir souhaité que ces quatre
sets
pour taper sur b sat et essayer de
revenir avec le fouet m leroy dans un
réseau
déjà tmb 5 j'ai envie de savoir combien
tu d'options cette tour des huit mais
bon tour des huit tours e rang
je vais
attaquer des pions
laurent
adam eve ça disons pour défendre parce
que ça ça a un coût a maintenant que tu
as joué autour des 8
et maintenant tout est flou
iachini
4.4
maintenant d'amd 5
c'est compliqué
ouais d'amd 5 maintenant je peux prendre
déjà ça c'est une idée que j'ai en tête
[Musique]
c'est bien dans ton style sera en plus
d'ailleurs ouais je pouvais pas vraiment
6,5 6,7
ça a l'air d'aller
après dame prend à deux c'est vrai que
tu prends un risque en parce qu'un petit
risque je pense qu'il ya moi je le vois
bien le tour des huit noms mais surtout
huit géants vite tu vas récupérer 4 way
est un timing c'est moins bien mais tu
as toujours ce
truc tu peux mettre 7 à moi aussi ça
tout le monde le sait si bien qu'il
fasse une boulette comme ça me prend 1,2
c est très très fort
de 3 6
[Musique]
3 ça peut donner envie au n
3 dans les trois gars qui dirige et
s'imagine nantes 3 à trois points
de plus on prend 1,3 mais kg si ça peut
être une option aussi aller dehors l'air
sympa oui à mon avis est down under
enfin moi je jouerai de toi tu étais
dirait chercher le pion à créac'h
riponne frivole juste une toute petite
solitude qui a une gaffe de rapporte
mais alors ouais alors dit dans un
avantage pour pour hadj abdou fall away
est ce que tu me laisses tours fc est où
là donc à travers
alors après faut voir
ses seins qui tombent et quatre ponts
ses sept enfants
[Musique]
après
un audit doit sans doute faire tourner
un jeu 4 et 3,4
vous trouverez 4
étoiles accepte on prend 1,5 à essayer
de faire nul sur la septième rangée quoi
j'aurai moi j'ai un projet reprocher
j'ai trois des
quatre fois de
l'ordi samba loi si on fait ça 2 est ce
que le truc c'est que re5 tout faire il
ya tous rêvent cette fois huit tours à
sa tête en ferme le vrai j'avais vu et
générait que tu puisse donner le fou
quelque part et celle et une paire de
touré et peut-être tu peux pas ensuite
ce que tu vois j'ai envie et admettons
que tu donnes le fou mais que des
changes une paire de tours pour moi
c'est nul parce que pion à de piocher
deux
étaient joués 5 tu vois le fou blanc est
pas or je pense que c'est mieux que
facile mais c'est change pas une peur de
toi
tu gardes le tout car toutes les tours
et tu veux ma bonne étoile et onu dynepo
et gagne on fait juste un petit tour des
stades rapide
et je suis quasiment sûr qu'en fait
c'est le plan défensif on
sait pas jouer ces cinq pour activer
j'aurais dit un truc genre touch 4g un
tour des huit tours à 7 tours 17 mais
bon ça donne des pions
n'êtes peut-être et avec le fonds et les
cinq
cas on avait une petite question pour
toi quand on joue contre eux fabiano moi
j'avais fait une imitation après que tu
avais des questions pour les infos
creuseurs après on va on va y arriver
après à tanger un appel est ce que ces
balades à l'eau
c'est pas ben laden
alors je suis pas surpris du niveau de
maipo puisque là puisqu'on est posée
j'ai dit que sa cote avait un tournoi
est bien un style une horreur des boucs
12 j'ai misé sur lui
c'est donc là qu'il a vraiment misé moi
je considère que j'ai plus grand 1 mais
miser alors avec les coéquipiers quoi
j'ai pris dépôts et cheyrou ou face à
ding et caro
donc maintenant la question fabiano
j'avais fait une imitation quand avait
joué contre lui au grand suisse j'avais
fait une longue imitation des poses de
fabiano qui change toutes les 30
secondes toutes les 15 secondes de
position et ses mains est-ce que c'est
pas pénible au bout d'un moment quand tu
es en face on est en remplacement de
stuart est en face déjà moi je me lève
c'est comme jouer il dérange pas trop en
plus mais voilà et
[Musique]
position mais moins qu'un pas mais j'ai
l'impression qu'ils changent rarement
souvent de positiver il est vrai qu il
ait pas de l'échaudé attaquer mais ça
donne enfin envie de dire à leur actif
label b mais il ya des joueurs qui
possèdent pas du tout cas qui par
exemple ont regardé y en a beaucoup plus
non mais c'est des petits tics nerveux à
rognan à renan et revivre à l'arbre
ironie fera les gagnants des vols ironie
face à celle d'yves agréable c'est
désagréable après un mois ça m'arrive de
tous et
devrait soulager des petites crises de
tous alors bon c'est absolument pas vous
permets tu pourrais te dire que c'est
quand même plus désagréable adversaire
que
que changer de position wesley so à un
moment
alors par contre je fais attention
tant de booba je vais pas tout c'est sûr
ça
fait quand même sympa voilà enac a du
coup beaucoup de gens qui demandent à
kaya les limites gaming le ciel est ce
que tu as vu d'ailleurs le même qu'ils
ont qu'ils ont fait avec michael
nas le gène as bien sûr j'étais à terre
quand j'ai vu ça j'étais par terre
exceptionnel mais
c'est leur message ils ont été très très
bon là dessus olala herald le pion en a
deux
au bon c'est sûr qu'il sera pris pour
moi je vais dire
[Musique]
non à canach a attiré l'annulent
supportable mais enfin j'ai pas compris
le bénir ce jeune hacker il ajoute
toutefois tempo donc la fin je vois pas
pourquoi il est tellement bien alors
après il ya un moment où la position
était chaude mais
pas trop sa posture c'était une prépa
d'accord
il ya toujours et en
qualité propre à maison c'est sûr
et wade sa chance crânement après ding
ding j'arrive pas le service je sais tu
as fait rich beem et parfois c'est pas
vrai s'est pris
l'avantagé quant à maxime avec toi c'est
que tu sais les coûts en fait c'est que
cela je sais que j'avais j'ai dit mb 5
après ouais encore une fois j'ai parlé
deux fois fin
mai d'abaisser le coût avec le plus de
ressources voilà déjà renvoyé claridge
et 6 mai peut-être quand même malgré
tout voir ouais ok j'ai si c'est aussi
mais ça ne m'aurait pas tolérer ça qui m
a souvent pas mal de ressources
de soutien dmb 5 justement pour
commencer à vraiment
remettre le bordel
mais peut-être que sur des messins qui a
aidé à mettre 7 kg 6
apparemment lors des sept matches dams
et deux pour fouet fin fous ces quatre
en disant qu'ils aient beaucoup de
pièces sur la diagonale est passé à c
est cette idée leur
[Musique]
est consac tout réussi c'était plus
précis que la presse il a dû avoir peur
de demander cinq je vois tempo tous les
coups la cei shirani f4 après c'est
mérité dans le sens où il s'est pas
laissé le temps de la réflexion ruinant
méritait bien sûr et radjabov +4 on nous
dit contre richard rapport est bon après
dams et de autant j'allais dans le d5
mesdames ses deux breaks c'est un coup
complètement évident à trouver
en plus tu me laisses je les avais je
l'avais même besnik tatavel de rêve en
une seconde doit
mais mesdames ces deux c'est un peu plus
dur parce que déjà tapas d'attac et
fouet f1 le public n'est plus protégé du
tout donc c'est plus dur que d'habitude
idénum dessins poèmes
et oui il veut alors après attention à
ne pas tomber dans l'excès inverse où il
habite sais où je vais dire n'a plus que
neuf minutes mais il a encore mal luné
dit
j'ai même plus une seconde parcours là
c'est n'importe quoi
elle nous fait vraiment une partie
catastrophique
après kf4 ainsi logique allait peut-être
fou j'ai quatre fois et encore une fois
c'est un peu 5 ou un peu en mode feu
follet voilà ce que leur état dès la
tournée le 8 ème partie l'acef 6 et vous
aussi si vous cavalier a bien réussi ce
doublé notre rôle de la colonne des
savoirs que si tu perds le contrôle de
cette colonne sais même pas où site
échange des tours c'est encore mieux
donc c'est un coup logique
n'a qu'à ça a beaucoup bougé depuis et
ça semble être perpète maintenant après
avoir fui tu d'un point sagesse j'ai eu
cette crise
donc ça va être nul entre le joueur
alors oui juste
ou à 3,17 faut pas jouer 6
je crois qu'avec sept mois 17h17 ya des
recettes mais si tu peux le dire tu
gagnes la dame ah oui à tour prend un
tour et ensuite tourache un échec sur le
banc
on va aller radjabov apparemment tour hk
3g un apparemment tour 4 x 2 ça doit
être gagnant donc radjabov peut la
gagner la cup a sillonné on leur dit la
ligne que tu as dit maxime tour des huit
tours 17
ouais il faut encore la gagne mais fois
qu'il a joué il a joué un rôle majeur
à jouer et les pots et pau ça sent la
fin
en fait là la question c'est pourquoi tu
joues tour des huit maintenant il passe
deux tours des huit ce
que tu peux dire qu'avec le fond h de ta
plus de chances d'obtenir tout cas il ya
un potentiel magouilles chez ali reza
qui fait plaisir
celle qui essayent de l'assuré azani
louis mathieu qui nous explique way pas
facile la défense est toujours 2e à la
fin j'ai
radjabov à 50% après six rondes pour moi
ce serait une surprise monumentale un
juste il ya montré surtout c'est à dire
que vous avez deux gardiens c'est enfin
encore une fois
riche il a joué ça contre fabiano hier
tu sais qu'ils jouent pour cette
position oui
il était moins bien besoin
comme dans tout à la réussite ah ouais
bien sûr
non même si parfois il a réussi deux
coups j'ai quatre mois j'aurais ajouté
si
allah y avait trois noms
de trois fois cet endroit est trop fort
à mes pions point
f25
définirait
le temps prévu trois tours détroit quand
même
trois tours de
3,4
alors ratchet le
merdier on nous dit et mathieu église ça
c'est mon rajhi ah oui oui il a raté il
a raté fourrage 2 alalalala mais non il
n'a pas joué non
oh
il a vu là nul laprise qui est l'erreur
tour bessin et c'est fini la m'attend
mais il a une heure à la pendule
vient de récupérer leur avec le 40e par
contre il avait quatre minutes
haha d'accord avec un j'ai rien dis non
non non c'est
précieux à mon avis la vue plonge de 5
il s'est arrêté
à 7 est en fête ou alors il apparaît
assez terrible assez terrible mais ouais
moi je peux enfin je veux dire gens j'ai
vu bien
nul ici est alors wayne et pochy imagine
que c'est
à l'air d'être matin
sent pas bon mais pau il veut donc
vraiment rejouer contre 40 cents
maintenant on le sait bien c'est vrai
oui car c'est le genre
toi tu pense qu'il jouera pas carlson
maxime
bas je pense qu'il y réfléchit
sérieusement c'est à dire qu'on peut
peut dire des trucs de magnus mais
souvent il est assez honnête dans ses
interventions il dit ce qu'il pense donc
s'il dit qu'il hésite à jouer un match
et que ça fait chier de bosser six mois
pour un match de championnat ce qu'on
soit moi ce qui m'étonne en fait c'est
qu'il a tout fait pour changer de format
moi c'est moi c'est ça mais je suis
d'accord avec toi ce qui m'étonne c'est
je comprends en fait qu'ils veulent plus
jouer mais ce que je comprends pas c'est
qu'ils donnent pas d'alternative sais
qui je veux plus jouer
et point barre quoi
après on compte je ne passe que il a
gagné le match
n'a rien à prouver à personne mais
encore une fois moi je pense t'il de
proposer une alternative
on
a continué sur ces matches ici ça ne
plaît pas
et honnêtement fin et une certaine un
historique machin sur les matches mais
quand s
c'est la dernière fois qu'on avait un
match de championnat à sepang en parler
français
je dirais
bizarrement très très bizarrement le
dernier vraiment intéressant à suivre
c'était caruana karl scène de deux par
la dramaturgie dénombre deux nuls mais
bon oui c'était c'était chiant en fait
c'est plus ça crée une dramaturgie dans
le son ça et masseube à cet essai
j'aurais vraiment bien mais
si nous
je dois presque un an même les matchs
avec beaucoup de victoires 15 minutes
mme flici ça pouvait tourner machin la
partie 6 mais au final
il y avait
avant que palop 2010 où est le
vraie vie tu sais pas s'il ya tellement
de surfacturation potter attend accueil
à il ya trois jours moi j'ai la rive
tempo
tempo et c'est sans doute le goût 3
c'est le bon coup et roy g2 et g2 je
pensais ben alaya alors dilemme un seul
coup pour les noirs
ford est vite bondée 8 ou
pas facile facile quand même
nom roger de celle beaucoup
réseau tempo
ouais bah oui mais encore une frange
mars au
mondial il n'a pas gagné le camp suisse
point rien à voir la grande rencontre de
vlad bus et planus ah là là c'est trop
c'est beaucoup trop
dingli rennes va gagner c'est sûr maxime
jeune et peu ne gagnera pas les
candidats
écoute avant le tournoi des 8 jouer
le vrai plus à huawei rival a gagné sa
place ils jouent tous il a joué verbe
est un incroyable henry joue
dassier surtout en terme de timing pris
ce que ça se trouve quand même tour des
huit
un peu par élimination mais ça se trouve
encore une fois je ne vais pas remettre
veut échanger c'est toi et il s'est levé
en plus ça fait très très mal
pro ça fait mal
quel monstre
allez on a tiré
honnêtement
ouais il sait tout faire bouger way
rencontre devra du ceva nous tu peux tu
peux venir s'asseoir
la rencontre au sommet bon moi j'ai été
sage écouter ça tiens on te laisse on
vous laisse tous les deux
allez
on te donne les écouteurs et on te
laisse avec le m on est de trop ici
maxime
années de trop évidemment il n'ya rien
de plus fort que flatus
yôrôbô axalot
la fine fleur your oui qu'est-ce que tu
as un point ça leur
bail coûte ouais on a dit pas mal de
choses déjà c'était de faire c'est que
bon on a vu des mêmes défauts anthony
reza qui sont pour moi principalement
due à un manque de confiance
naturelle
[Musique]
tu prends un tournoi c'est donc qu'il se
passe pas très bien tu perds un peu
confiance en nous et je pense que c'est
se passe
mais bon malgré tout c'est vrai que ça
m'étonne surtout pour moi tu vois tu me
connais tu sais que je vais jamais
prendre trop de temps pour jouer une
position parfois pas assez
c'est sûr que moi je comprends pas
comment c'est possible d'autant que de
faire de cette façon leur assure des
positions parce que
sans toi aussi tu penses qu'il se fait
bien asséché comme en étant dans les
trois premiers rangs de danse finale
teddy quoi est ce qu est ce que tu
penses aussi comme enfant et c'est trop
à nu est d'aller trois premiers rounds
campays à chaque fois il s'agissait de
finale médias trop de trop de dépenses
d'énergie ouais ouais bien sûr tous et
pas de l'énergie fissile qu'à ce niveau
là c'est plus de l'énergie mentale en
fait
c'est plus ça qui maintenant lui fait
défaut c'est possible
qu'est ce que tu penses aujourd'hui
quand elle est à la fois autour de cette
date de cette fois je trouve à la fois l
express où il avoue preuve 505 d'amour
là je sais pas la certitude je dirais
quand même qu'il a vu mais
enfin s'il était en confiance je serai
certain qu'il a vu mais là bon c'est
possible qu'il vous plaît parce que moi
j'ai eu cette impression là en fait
parce que je pense des loupés pas si
j'allais au je pense que le groupe ait
20 hockey
et donc qu'est-ce que ça tombe
maintenant ce moment là alors
là car on a trouvé tous les noms moi je
veux dire maintenant il faut qu'on
relève sa part être plus ou moins
désespérant
ouais
mais aussi son corps mais toujours ces
deux on est déjà parent de menaces et
2006 encore là il ya des meneurs sont
mes cd pas encore menacés de 1,6
là je cahier à vii bas il joue très vite
j'imagine que si seul coup on a laissé
faire michel 5
bois crois que ça complètement désespéré
[Musique]
sinon f6 et g5 3,4
mais faut voir si tour ces deux se
termine pas la partie juste
bas salaires
d'ailleurs regardez encore c'est de tout
de suite
non non cavaliers aussi ou mais bon
après
ça près oui f1 tous ces mois de prépa
pour sortir cette prestation parfois
parfois la préparation justement c'est
entre guillemets contre productif sur
cet événement là après tu en retire les
bénéfices pour les tournois suivants
mais ça peut arriver tu peux être aussi
bien préparé que tu puisses être
humainement et
le problème c'est que ça le jour j ça va
pas
ça t'arrive de jackie o pour un grand
tournoi te préparer énormément de choses
t'as pas eu le poignet t2 utiliser sa
part dans ce grand tournoi est en fait
tout est serti jeannard ya un an et demi
plus tard ouais ouais après je prenais
même pas de ce
suivi des malades c'est un
truc j'attends encore de presser
non mais
c'est naturel mais l'âge parce que là
les rezaï l'a eue ces prépas qui sont
tombés
mais parfois juste
quand et pas dans le mood que
une dépression mais dans le sens était
pas d'impacter
la pâte et repères habituels tu joues
pas tu es tu lâches pas tes coups de la
même façon de la confiance se perd et
même en été aussi bien préparé que
possible en tout cas s'ils tiennent mans
après tu en avais parlé
c'est un point qui est
trop négligée alors beaucoup c'est le
mental évidemment après je sais pas je
sais pas du tout ce qu'à lire les
affaires
d'ailleurs qu'est ce qui se passe à
l'heure d'aller partie donnée peau
ou les gagnants ah oui complètement
d'ailleurs aurait du coup on va voir un
duel à deux ça sent
les parties de la journée restions ça